He directed people towards their docks knowing that it made them
leave before. He just he does it repeatedly and then he can come
on and say, "Hey, post proof of this or else you're lying." It's
like, "No, nobody's lying. What the what are we doing here?"
That's what made Jacob and Zoe turn against him was Zoe went,
"Oh, holy [__] This guy sent me a bunch of stuff
non-consensually. That's really [__] crazy. Oh, he's
actually a total piece of shit." Could you imagine if Assan did
this? Holy, the internet would explode. Could you imagine if
Assan did this? if he was like, "Actually, yeah, I do hope those
people die. Yeah, I do want somebody to go kill them." And then
every time people are like, "Hey, do you mind like taking that
back and saying you don't want that?" And he's like, "No, here's
all the reasons why it's a good thing. Here's all the reasons
why I do still have those." Wait, he literally says it.
you come on,
dude. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Well, I mean, probably there will be
a video of this whole segment, so I wouldn't worry about it.
Kenny's losing his mind. Kenny, are you okay? Kenny, you got
to be okay. I hope you're okay. All right.
Okay. We just about ready to go with this.
Kelly, that's a question for you, Kelly. Oh, sorry. You didn't
say my name, so I didn't know you were talking to me. Um, yeah,
sure. I'm ready. All right. Uh, apparently this when you're talking
to like your uh I don't know when you're talking to like your
audience when you're talking. Most of the time. Most of the time
to you. Most of the time, but it's okay. I don't think most of
the time. All right, I'm going to hit play on this. I'm listening
in the background. I turn the music down just a little bit more.
Just a little bit more. And I'm in the the balanced question
then. Uh I I would say 2022 in my opinion. Okay. B I don't have
any specific insight. Uh however, in 2022, I would say that based
off of uh what's publicly out there, that was probably the maximum
of your pleasure seeking behavior. So, at the time and now, sorry,
did you view your I thought you said you wanted the video before
Vegan Games joined.
I'm just watching from this point. This is where he starts talking
about the 2022 stuff. Oh, okay. I Yeah, sorry. Watching the Destiny
counterpoints combo. Oh, there it is. I would say that based
off of
uh what did you ask? Be very vivic. That was the maximum he wasn't
he in Miami by Uh yeah, sure. So I guess the maximum would be
including the Anavore stuff which I guess probably went into
2021, but realistically before that it was the Bob 7 stuff, right?
With them like all these different women having massive [__]
going on. I have to have ADHD. Um maybe I just didn't have time
to set up for today cuz I slept the I slept way in. So to burn
out like there should be maybe you do. Why you take the meds
for it? You have ADHD. Oh, sure. Yeah. Yeah, I was saying it's
not what we're exhibiting here. Joy society and society as well.
So, one thing,
my just broken.
Oh, I wanted to read out just thinks he's different than Kelly
when she gets preemptively bored of something that hasn't been
described to her yet.
I thought that was a good chat. You do think you're different.
You're just the same. That was an incredible chat message. Thank
you very much for pausing the video so you get that right up
to everybody. Kelly, thank you. Thank you. Awesome. Like roughly
st my position out there and then Yeah. Go ahead. No. M m making
uh the the balanced question then uh I I would say 2022 in my
opinion. Okay. Um I don't have any specific insight. Uh however,
in 2022, I would say that based off of uh what's publicly out
there, that was probably the maximum of your pleasure seeeking
behavior. So at the time and now
um did you view your pleasure seeking as balanced with your prog
uh your prescriptive moral duties at that time? Um and then now
uh considering that you know I've heard you mention that you
got on medication some of your perceptions around sex is just
saying do you think being like a complete degenerate was a good
idea? Do you think like do you think that's do you think that
aligns with your what you think your mission is have changed
a little bit? Cool. Um I don't know if they've changed. May maybe
your behaviors around things have changed a little bit. Um do
you feel like they're better calibrated now and how? Okay, so
um one part about this conversation that's annoying is that when
people say pleasure seeing air or hiddenist it um there's been
a huge push back socially uh even in my community and notice
all the internet in response to the red pill people who are like
super unhinged about anything related to sex. Um, most of I think
most of Destiny's uh arguments, they essentially always come
down to this one thing. You're you're being too hyperbolic. Therefore,
I don't have to take you seriously. He doesn't actually say why
it's too hyperbolic or he doesn't even address like the like
where it actually is. For some reason, his community has been
into thinking that if somebody else is hyperbolic, they're wrong
by definition, right? But he doesn't actually like engage going
backwards in the other direction at all. Right? So, he won't
go like if somebody goes, "Okay, like if this happened, right?"
He'll go and he'll say, "Oh, you're being really hyperbolic.
You said I have like too much. Actually, you said I'm like totally
ruled by sex. So, you know what? Realistically, yeah, I had a
little bit of sex, but is it more than that?" And it's like he
doesn't actually engage with like, "Oh, but it also like blew
up a bunch of your relationships and your need to people like
actually drove you to apparently sharing a bunch of non-consensually
with other people, right? Like, it actually has hurt you significantly.
The your actions have hurt you significantly. not rhetoric about
your actions, your actions, right? But he doesn't really engage
with that at all. He just goes, "You're being really hyperbolic
when you said like I'm I'm totally ruled by I can't control myself."
That was being so hyperbolic. I actually don't want to I actually
don't want to uh have a conversation with you anymore. You're
just bad faith. You're just bad faith.
That's broadly that's his flavor of argument for almost all of
these. Since when was he against
True. True. Yeah. True. But that is his broad argument is like
it's a serious conversation. You're being hyperbolic about it.
That means I don't have to talk to you. Obviously, there's a
huge push back online now that where people have Destiny known
for hanging up on people. I think the last two or three conversations
I had with him, he hung up on me. He got really really assigned
about the bet. He left. What was the one before that? He left
some other one too. He just he would do that a lot. Yeah. These
like kind of puritanical views I would argue about. So basically
any pursuit of recreational. Uh in the forethought conversation
we had, he said, "Oh, you're being hyperbolic about this. You
called this a hate threat. I don't even want to have this conversation
with you anymore. Yeah, he actually does that quite a lot. Makes
you a total and complete utter hedonist. Um, if people want to
have that view, that's fine. I'm hold on hold on unhinged about
listen listen to the argument. He's doing it in the moment. As
I said, this is going to be his argument. He's actually doing
people say pleasure seeing hidden sing it. Um, there's been a
huge push back socially even in my community and notice all the
internet in response to the red pill people who are like super
unhinged about anything related to space. Um obviously there's
a huge push back online now that where people have these like
kind of puritanical views I would argue about. So basically any
pursuit of recreational makes you a total and complete utter
hedonist. Um yeah so th this is nobody's position clearly. Literally
nobody has the position of any recreational engagement with he
is in fact doing the hyperbolic thing himself. Right? like he
just totally made up a straw man that nobody has said once ever
and acted like that's the criticism that upsets him, but that's
totally fake and non-existent and he's totally making that up.
Yeah. If you want to have that view, that's fine. I'm never going
to be able to communicate with those people. It's whatever. Yeah.
I don't think I don't think Connor has that view. I don't think
literally anybody has that view. It's just a totally constructed
thing that he made up that he's going to pretend other people
think or say ever. Um, in terms of like my balance of stuff,
I would say that the biggest things that have changed in my mind
are wanting to be more um effective in terms of actualizing like
a political view that I have and seeing that come out in the
world. Uh, as an online streamer person, that's like fairly difficult.
Nobody else was really doing it at all. Um, so like I tried to
figure out like, well, what's a way to make a positive impact?
people floated the canvasing idea or somebody reached out and
we started to do uh I don't know how much this was Steven managing
this and him just having Sedon as a super engaged part of his
community that he gave money to and then Sedon ran everything.
I don't think Destiny from what I understand when Sedon would
go to run canvasing stuff. Destiny basically would be borderline
unworkable with. He would never show up for meetings. He would
just he would be uncontable and Sedon would just get the money
to set it up and Sedon was passionate and Sedon got it done.
That's broadly my understanding of how canvasing worked. Destiny
was a money bank and he did he did want to help as from a money
perspective, but he was never somebody who was engaged and like
wanted to put work into it ever canvasing stuff. Um try to bag
a mayor in New York uh not in New York in um Omaha. Um and then
that's kind of like what I've looked at. Progressive Victory
was a company that spawned out and basically ended up hiring
off a ton of my community to do stuff. And so that's yeah. So
it's kind of like trying to find a way to like how do I how do
I like make a politically positive or effective change pushing
in that direction while still being a content creator or whatever.
Yeah. So that's the thing that I've pushed more um in the direction
of. But I don't think that any of this has come at like the where
I've been like oh like I can't you know do things that are fun
or oh like this was holding me back before. Like the doing incredibly
dramatic content before was was a part of my stream. Like it
it was really good for viewership. I enjoyed doing it. It was
fun. Um, at the time that's that was just what the content was
or whatever. Yeah. Well, then then I guess my question is, have
you So, you could make the argument that, oh, the incredibly
dramatic content allowed me to get the money that allowed people
to canvas, right? You could make that argument if you wanted
to make that argument. I don't know if he's going to change your
mind on the dramatic content or how you engage with people on
an interpersonal level because for for instance, like I I think
a lot of your by the way uh my criticisms at least have never
been, oh, you make dramatic content. you you use your real life
as content and therefore you're a bad person. So, I don't know
who makes that argument either, right? I don't know who's making
that argument that you can engage in dramatic content. Conor
is saying like, do you think the dramatic This is probably from
Connor's like uh weird framing of the question. What Connor wants
to say is you're a degenerate. Your degenerate behavior has led
to people being against you. Do you regret that? Is that bad?
And was I correct about your degenerate behavior? Right? That's
what Conor's trying to say. Now, he's not because he doesn't
really know or he can't like specify the actual degenerate behavior.
He is having a hard time like getting Destiny to answer questions
or even respond in like a like a what do you call it like a reasonable
way or engage with the question. Your critics are going to point
to the events of 2022. Uh I think that some things that uh people
in your community and maybe you have pointed out as well is that
there hasn't been a substantive criticism of your personal behavior
that dated into 24 or 25. The non-consensual sharing dated into
24.
The the um behaviors in 25 would be the death threats, the doxing
threats, the constant menacing of victims, right? Uh leaking
texts about Pixie, leaking texts about Cherry and anyone that
supports the victims as well, trying to intimidate them. Yeah,
sure. Well, I mean, that was the doxing and uh and death threats,
right? The death threats compelling people to violence. Yeah,
it's not just Doc saying death threats though. I mean I I mean
if you go by like the doc like it says like there were 15 women
and a lot of the others were intimidated into dropping out. I'm
sure that's quite true.
Yep. I mean that was true of lots of women. Lots of women made
new Discord accounts to make like to just they didn't want anybody
to be able to attach anything to their old their actual identity.
They were so terrified of retribution. Same thing with Far. Same
thing with Jasmine. They're so terrified of retribution that
they will not they will not talk about anything even though they
have direct evidence of this person breaking the law. They they
don't care. They will not they don't want to risk any aspect
of their lives or they either already know just how bad it is
like Molina, right? Cuz she just knows how bad it is. He just
doesn't want to be involved at all. though his intimidation works
quite effectively cuz he's a very shitty person and he will will
wield his audience to do absolutely anything including things
he's complained about himself before. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Uh all
the time. Yes. He's obviously a hypocrite. But the big one, the
very big one here that um I just lost it. You you started talking.
I I had another thing here. Oh, sorry. The reason he gets away
with this is the cultlike audience, right? the cultlike audience
who will be convinced by arguments that are terrible, right?
Like he has he's built up this aura of being correct and he's
built up not just his own community, but like an outer rim of
communities. I don't think any of this is intentional, by the
way. It just happened to happen over time where like the horrible
arguments he uses, you're being hyperbolic, so I don't have to
take you seriously. Things like this, they actually are even
people who don't really like him will still bend to that kind
of argumentation without really thinking at all. Right? So there
are like a lot of people who one are in his like direct cult
and a lot of people who are in like the adjacent spaces who are
completely cognitively raped by the terrible arguments he makes
who don't really who don't really think about it. They're just
like oh yeah that guy is being hyperbolic and that does mean
he's incorrect. Amazing. He's built up being able to debate bro
anything and that is somehow makes him right. Yeah. Basically
it's something like this. Sorry. It's like why would you want
to be on his bad side unless you have to type of thing. And I'm
not saying that everyone is a coward who does that. It's more
like do you want that hassle? It's like the hassle's not worth
it to you, right? It's just a lot to deal with. That's most of
the women who have had their opinion on consensually leaked by
him. I would say that's the that's the direction they've gone
in. That's the argument they've made overall is well um the the
leaked and it's not leaked online publicly, right? That would
be most most of the women they it's not publicly leaked, right?
And they're like, "Well, so I have no upside to accusing him
or saying anything about him, right?" So they they're just like,
"I won't I won't testify. I don't need to because obviously um
Pixie had a whole bunch of [__] leaked about her.
He's got a bunch of intimate about me. I'm not going to risk
getting that that [__] happening to me. Oh, the people
who are like covering this stuff, they're actually getting death
threats and oh well, I'm not going to I'm not going to cover
any of that. Like I'm I'm not going to sorry. I'm not going to
step into that. I don't want to be a part of that. I don't want
death threats. I don't want to be doxed. I don't want his audience
coming after me. I don't want any of that." Right. Also, I will
say one thing because some of the names in that docket were like
public. I don't know if that was a good thing because it means
that Destiny could go and then sort of like intimidate them privately.
I don't know if I would say you broadly don't know any of those
names had revenge shared or if they had revenge shared to them.
You don't sorry non-conensual being shared to them. We don't
know who any of those people like we don't know anybody who isn't
public. We don't know what happened with them. So, I'd say probably
like there's no reason for him to go after them yet, right? Cuz
they haven't said anything. They haven't commented publicly.
To be fair, you are assuming a lot. I'm assuming what there,
Steven Jellian. What do you think I'm assuming there? I would
like to hear that, but um maybe I'll hit play for just a quick
second here.
Sherry and so, oh, hold on. I'll back it up. Kelly, you didn't
have anything else you wanted to say. I just want to hear Stephen
Jelly respond. No, it's okay. I will add I feel like the latency
has got slightly worse. So if I'm interrupting it's not intentional
for whatever reason. There's like a I want to say three or 4
second delay. We'd have to like test it properly at one point
but yeah kind of bad. Also I do have a kick account but it's
like I couldn't log into my other one. So like
that one is mine. I just couldn't remember my login. So if that
if you see that one is me. It's not just an impersonator. So
okay. Uh, let's see here. The reason why people drop their names.
Drop their names. What do you mean? Oh, no. That it's explicitly
said because of intimidation. And that is a persistent fear of
everybody who's talked about this to me and anyone else that
I've talked to who's had uh any victim or any witness come forward
is the persistent fear of Destiny attacking them. Yeah. I mean,
he says he wants he wants you guys to be dead.
He's a coward for not saying that he wants me to be dead, though.
What a coward.
Sure. All right. Anyway, so we can continue that there hasn't
been he just wants to deplatform substantive criticism of your
personal behavior that dated into 24 or 25 except for maybe Sherry.
And so the without getting specific, we can I don't care. We
can do whatever you want. Um in terms of 2022, what was say that
first part of that again? So I we can get specific if you want.
If you want to keep it vague, we can. Uh, but I think that as
far as what was known on stream, that was like the zenith of
drama. This was the personal Anna Mr. Girl Lab stuff.
Anna, Mr. Girl Lav, and then also like communications with Rose,
I think, was summer of 2022. Sure, but that was public until
202, right?
Yes. So, in terms of um so in terms of love, Mr. Girl, Anna,
the Anna stuff shouldn't have been content, I don't think. Um,
I didn't know until I hung out with this person. I didn't know
that OCD could manifest in such a way and that it ended up becoming
content because this person who is an adult and was an adult
and was basically my age um decided that they wanted to make
it a 247 stream topic for them which I Go ahead. Where's my hat?
Yeah, sure. It's you want fine for live. Um, so basically shouldn't
have been a stream topic. The So I I should I'll actually start
writing these down. So uh I'm going to write them down on a different
screen here. shouldn't shouldn't have been a stream topic.
So, Anna shouldn't have been a stream topic. So, I'm going to
have a conversation with Counterpoints after this either tonight
or another night. We'll see when it happens precisely. Um, I'm
going to have a conversation with about this and he said like,
"Oh, write down any questions you have for me." So, one I would
say is right here when Destiny says, "Anna shouldn't have been
a thing. Uh, I didn't know OD OCD managed uh manifested that
way." What I would say is, okay, when she was concerned about
her docs being on Kiwi Farms, you had a direct line to her. Why
did you go to your stream and say, "Go, everybody right now,
if you want to talk about Anna, go to her Kiwi Farms thread."
Why was that an appropriate avenue for you now that you've stated,
"Oh, there's docs there and doxing is basically trying to kill
people. These are quotes directly from Destiny." Okay? Why would
you take the thread where Anna's doc's information was that she
was very scared of and publicly say on your stream? All of you
guys should go to Annavar's Kiwi Farms thread. Why would you
do that precisely? Right? That should be that should be Connor's
follow-up question here. Why did you do that? You've said you
think it's getting people killed. That's what you're that's your
opinion, right? Basically, that doxing is trying to get somebody
killed, which by the way is going to get very interesting later
on, too. So, why did you do that? Right? But that that is the
question I would expect him to follow up with. Mr. Girl, uh Mr.
Live were really good ass stream content. I think it was super
enjoyable having them on. It was fun stuff at the time. Um yeah,
I don't I think I would probably stand by the content back then.
I think it was good ass content. Yeah, we explored some serious
issues. It's not a debate. I I don't think that that's the question
uh that that I'm necessarily pointing at. So uh everybody enjoyed
it, right? The the issue is Connor isn't being specific about
the issues right here. He's saying, "Oh, cuz Connor I think unfortunately
Connor seems to still be laboring under the delusion that because
this was in 2022, it's old Destiny behavior and he has changed
significantly." Right? That's the delusion Connor has to maintain
to be able to hop on stream and be okay with this person, right?
So that's that's what he needs to do and it's just not true.
But I mean, we'll we'll keep watching. Right. The the reason
why if I remember correctly, one of the historical details was
Lav found you through the Anna content. Right. So So the the
I think I think so. I think there I think there's literally the
Instagram DMs were, "Hey, I saw your content. I thought it was
good." Blah blah blah blah blah. Or at least at least this is
what Destiny said she had asked. I remember that. I don't remember
if it was over the Anna content. It might have that's possible.
It's possible. It might have been. I just don't remember. I don't
I thought it was before that, but actually I'm probably repeating
a Chudlo Logic drama summary, so if I'm wrong, I'm going to blame
Chudlogic. But the
the the point is that my my question, I guess, is so you had
these political things that you were trying to be effective in.
The canvasing in Omaha, Nebraska, then not as much, but yeah.
the the canvasing in Omaha, Nebraska, the canvasing in Cincinnati,
the canvasing in Milwaukee, the work with PV, the work up until
the relationship, uh the orbit. So the the question shouldn't
be, do you think your behavior with these people, these drama
involved people on stream, do you think that affects your real
world stuff? I would say, do you think your lack of concern for
humans, for other human beings, your uh your habitual violation
of women's consent, do you think that affects your previous statements,
your whole blue pill arc and stuff? And do you think that conflicts
with like some of your stuff publicly? Do you think your habitual
consent violations might actually spider out and cause people
to not want to deal with you politically? That that's what Connor
should be saying, but he's making it about Mr. Girl. I don't
know why Mr. girl would be brought up in any of this. There's
no reason to allow Mr. Girl into this conversation from a like,
hey, do you think the Mr. Girl stuff might make you look bad?
No, that's like a that's totally outside of what should be discussed
here. I'm not sure, but like when he speaks about Max, it gave
me the impression that he's spoken to Max. I could be wrong on
that. He could have just like gone over his stuff recently, but
I did think it was kind of random the stuff that he was bringing
up if he hadn't spoken to him. Like the Max stuff is just irrelevant
the the to this like it's relevant in that Max was also harassed,
Max was also like but I'm saying in terms of this whole this
whole weird narrative about it being 2022 is just odd to me.
It's very very odd the focus on22. That's Destiny always pushing
things back three years more than it really is. It's like why
not? Yeah. It's between two and four years ago. I'm like brother
are you okay?
Sure. like orbits were obviously incredibly profitable for all
involved uh either socially or economically to be a dest he won't
agree with the premise that he has persistent consent violations
but he does he like objectively does yeah like he he objectively
does this has already been proven persistent consent violations
yeah could say oh well I don't but it's like Molina Stasia Pixie
you admitted to the Pixie one right um the recordings where your
phone's in your pocket before you meet the Obviously all very
bad persistent consent violations are proven. I don't have to
go prove those. This was all, you know, a lot of people enjoyed
themselves while they were doing it, right? Also, this is a real
quick thing. So, Lav first gave me on Instagram in 2021 in November.
So, I don't know. I don't think there if he doesn't agree, then
you won't get anywhere is their their point. That's fine. And
he can disagree, right? But it he doesn't it doesn't matter if
he disagrees because the persistent consent violations are all
in one DM chain. Unless you unless you are delusional enough
to believe that it only happened in that one DM chain despite
I think it's uh it's Mama the true mama person on Twitter already
saying that yes no publicly a bunch of these videos were sent
to me that were in the Kiwi Farms leaks. Right. So like there's
at least two women but there are way more than those two women
just as a fact check. Okay, go ahead. So, so the uh but the point
being that obviously the drama cycle and the fallout from the
drama cycle and the fallout from the orbiters, I would say that
that was probably the reason why uh some more serious political
work was heavily criticized was because of people's anger as
a result of the drama content and the ensuing content, right?
Was that happen on the for the political content or for like
the canvasy stuff? I think that mostly h I think that mostly
happened with Omaha. Uh I don't think it happened as much with
Cincinnati and Wisconsin, but I would say that what's going to
happen is Wait, wait, wait. I think I think it's really important
for to factually have like all the stuff here because it'll inform
like my decision-m at the time for the Omaha stuff, the major
crash out for that I'm still listening. I have to let my dog
out. I'm listening. Yeah, the Omaha stuff came down to the um
written house comments. That was that that's what that's what
happened. Um, I would say the the what do you call it? The connector
here would be the lack of impulse control, right? The lack of
him having an impulse of like, hey, this could work out favorably
for me and then critically evaluating that impulse and saying
like, oh, I should I should do this. This is why he is not a
good political actor for any movement you want to be attached
to. Because he will always continually habitually ruin and and
denigrate those movements through like he will prioritize himself.
whatever he wants in that given moment, whatever makes him feel
happiest, that's the priority. It's never anybody else. There
is no other calculation that happens there in terms of that's
what connects the Lauren, like leaking Lauren Southern's kid's
name to Rose, the 19-year-old, and multiple other people. That's
what le links um leaking non-consentual. That's what links him
doing the non-consentual recording all of the time, right? Non-consensual
recording all of the time through all these other people. That's
what links the non-consensual sharing of other people. It's just
a lack of concern. It's all a lack of impulse control and a lack
of concern for other people and considering them in the same
way he considers himself. Sharing your wife's therapy document.
Oh, sharing Molina's therapy document. Sure. To that also. Yes.
That one just breaks my mind more than the other. I don't know
why. It's just for me that's such a I think that would just break
me. Yeah. No, it's [__] up. Obviously, it's [__]
up. It's called psychopathy. Um I I feel like narcissism is a
probably a bigger one,
right? Like the uh it's just it's being a bad person. It's just
being a horrible human being. Sure. But wouldn't that be like
a general criticism that you're a hyperbolic character?
Sure, but that's a significantly different thing than what we
were talking about before.
Oh, is it a mirrored is it a mirrored shot here? What is What
is the lightning bolt being carved in right here? Damn. I I'll
concede that it's substantively different. Whoa. Okay.
So, it's not a it's not a thing, but Connor Connor isn't connecting.
And this is why I try I hoped that he would consider the Lauren
Southern the the do not doxing the leaking the the unknown name
the previously unknown name of Lauren Southern's son to the 19-year-old
he' never met leaking Molina's therapy document to multiple women.
um like elements of this that go beyond because otherwise Connor
can just go it's all it's all it's not um it's just it's stuff
and as long as the stuff's fixed he's fixed but that's not what
it is. You got a bunch of new guns. Yeah, he got an AR-15 or
something. I think someone was saying he will escalate like this
type of level of intimidation to extreme circumstances. And I
don't I don't I mean I guess it works, right? Cuz if all you
want to do is just keep streaming and just intimidate absolutely
everyone around you and keep going because nobody cares about
sociopaths cuz half of streamers are sociopaths. So it's just
like whatever, I guess.
Yep. I just want to be clear. Yeah, we're going. Well, so so
what I would say he uh sorry, he never ever gets to complain
about his audience being nothing but incelss from now on. There
will be no more misogyny arcs because that's all he has left.
Uh, sure. Yeah. I mean, there will be new people who come in
for politics, but yeah, he'll broadly have that that same base
of people who I I again, it's just like uh he's just Ethan Ralph.
He's just like a a more intelligent, better arguing Ethan Ralph.
It's just the same human being on a base level. Uh let's say
what I would say or different sorry his actions like of what
he wants like contradict like what he does right so like he doesn't
want an entire audience of misogynist and incelss he doesn't
necessarily like cuz he's complained about that so many times
in the past but his actions cultivate that right so it's like
I don't think he is happy with that but I guess he just gets
to suffer in the hell that he's made I don't I I don't know.
I mean, I'm not sure if it's hell if he's just making $10,000.
It just seems like he's fine.
Um, if he was fine, he would have more of his beard by now.
Sure, sure, sure. I would say he did lose a lot of, I guess,
the people who are very, very close to him. It seems like, seems
like. Yeah. What real friends does he have? Can you stop pressing
the play button so fast? Either that can't just be latency, right?
You're pressing it like a minute. Oh, no. I try to Yeah, I try
to stop dinner from happening. So I hit play when you pause when
you like when you finish second but you know I'm on like a 3se
second latency. I'm I sure I just it's dead air lack of dead
air is very good for the stream. So I just hit play most of the
time when you're um yeah when you pause. But also I was going
to say the other thing is it's just like um one thing that's
really been proven out is this person is just completely untrustworthy
in like every way. Destiny makes 10k. Oh sorry did I say 10k?
Sorry. It's more like 100k. Like 100k a
Yeah. Um, wait, is that probably still true? It might not be
with kick. I'm actually not sure. In any case, um, where was
I? Yes. Uh, untrustworthy. Like, anything private that you give
this guy is going to end up public, right? Yep.
Like that's that should be what concerns anybody who works with
him from a political perspective or romantic or friendly or viewership
perspective that anything private by the way is included in him
leaking all of the all of what the group text where they discussed
for anything else all the payment details because he was angry
at Dan that Dan wanted to monetize anything else right why would
you leak all of your private negotiations over over splits between
him and August and Dan why would you leak all of that to a third
party who you don't know very well right? Which he he did. He's
just not a trustworthy person. Anything you trust him with, you
cannot. Now, that broadly could apply to most streamers. But
I'm saying that this guy in general trying to be a political
like entity, he's just not a trustworthy person in any any way
whatsoever. He's a completely untrustworthy person. Did you ever
go into detail about that? Like the stuff that he sent you?
No, I could just go through the logs if we wanted, but um just
to show that he did. All for him is leverage. Yeah, basically.
I mean, I know that you did, right? Because you showed me the
proof of it, but you didn't send me exactly what was sent. So,
I guess even I'm curious. Wasn't it like data and stuff? Uh,
it was just them talking about it in a group chat. It was a group
chat between the stakeholders and anything else. And they were
talking about what the splits should be. Weird. Why would you
send someone? It's like not um it's not as relevant now because
it included stuff on like how much their costs were and Destiny
was upset because Dan was saying, "Oh, we're not making any money."
But they were already making profit and their their costs were
basically nothing. So Destiny was upset that Dan was basically
lying publicly about whether or not they were making money yet.
And I got sent that and I was like, "You know what, Dan? I don't
want to leak that you lied about this to anybody. So I'm going
to I'm going to go ahead. I'm going to keep this to myself cuz
I'm on your side, Dan. I don't want you to get blown up by the
community." Oh my god, what a dumb decision that was. I should
have just tried to rape him completely with that info Destiny
gave me and then leaked that everywhere or something. I don't
know. Would have been better. Would have been smarter. But you're
saying it should have been me.
Uh maybe. But anyway, me and I I basically the way I handled
myself there, I just say like, "Oh, wasn't smart." And um I ended
up being good with Dan after that, so not a big deal. Well, my
way didn't really work out either. I don't think there is like
a positive way you can deal with those people if you don't accept
that they're just like there's no like there's no winning. There's
no like right decision because there isn't one. It's just Yeah.
I don't know.
Uh yeah, broadly it's just like um interacting with them at all
is just an L. I don't know. Are we anti-Dan again? No, we're
not anti-Dan. I'm just saying that like it doesn't matter now
cuz everybody's fine with how anything else is set up, right?
It doesn't It literally doesn't matter now. I'm not anti-Dan
at all. It was just like that was what I didn't blow him up for
was like lying about the costs and what it what it was at that
point anyway. Yeah. Well, I mean, it also might have just been
his perspective, right? Like, it's not making enough money. It
might have been in profit, but not not enough for him to deem
worthwhile.
I don't know the context, so I'm just taking what you've said.
Right. Yeah. Maybe to Dan, like if it was only like five grand
or something, Dan's like, "This is nothing." Like, I don't know.
I
Uh-huh. Okay. In any case, I'm going to hit play and we're going
to continue on with this content. Character,
you sure? But that's a significantly different thing than what
we were talking about
Sure. I I'll concede that it's substantively different. Okay.
Okay. I just want to be clear on that. Yeah. Go ahead. Well,
so so what I would say is uh let's say it's PV or a different
organization and they're like, "Hey, Stephen, we're still trying
to figure out how to do the alternative media stuff. We want
you,
uh, you know, do mobilizations for the midterms or we want you
to do this volunteer thing. We want you to do this. We want you
to do that in order to try to have a real world effect, then
I think that your greatest critics are going to use the drama
content, Mr. Girl, Lav,
uh, other characters, uh, that they're going to use that as a
weapon. Drama content, Mr. Girl, Lav, those were not the major
transgressions. Those are not what caused anybody to walk away
from him. That's not what caused anybody to be mad at Connor.
And so, giving him this question, in my opinion, to Connor, I
would be like, this is like a softball. This is like you sort
of sweeping here. I I don't need to like attack him with that,
but when you ask that question, that question actually doesn't
make any sense, right? Because that is not the approximate cause
of Destiny's troubles right now in terms of people collaborating
with him or whatever else. It's just not at all the approximate
cause in order to try to derail your realworld efforts.
Yeah. At this point, probably. Yeah. Okay. So, so what what I
So, like this is I'd say this is like totally disingenuous. It
would be like Desessie, do you think your like evidence coming
out that you totally disregarded the the consent of your ex-wife
um your former co-host, not co-host, your former orbiter and
one of your former fans, do you think that hurts you, Destiny?
Do you think leaking the therapy document of your ex-wife to
a random like 17 or 19year-old on Discord that you were getting
feet pics and nudes from that you were paying for those? Do you
think that was a good idea? Do you think that's going to affect
your political canvasing going forward that you were trying to
do this? Desessie, do you think um leaking the name of your the
person you purported to love um her son that she's tried to keep
off the internet desperately, do you think leaking that to the
same 17 or 19year-old who you bought feet pics from, do you think
that was a good idea? Do you think that makes you a less reliable
political actor would be the question? Right, Destiny, do you
think leaking every private piece of information that you possibly
could? Do you think leaking all of these things, right, do you
think leaking it all to the same Discord kitten that you are
paying for nudes, do you think that is going to affect your political
project going forward? That would be the more accurate question.
Bringing in Lav and Mr. Girl, that's all sort of like loading
things that people aren't super concerned about. The I I'll just
say it instead of asking questions. I would say that while the
content was enjoyable during 2022, there were people who probably
got seriously emotionally damaged as a result. And then as a
result of that emotional damage, they're lashing back out at
you. And then they're making the we divided it into pleasure-
seeeking versus prescriptive moral duties. In my opinion, the
pleasure seeking has damaged your capacity to carry out your
prescriptive moral duties. That while arguably that might be
true, I would say that um I mean there's no way to know how like
different aspects of your life I guess could change or will change
or whatever. So like for instance, right now I'm not in school.
There might be things I'm saying or doing now that are going
to that would severely hurt my ability to um go to law school
or something. I don't know something like that. Um the nature
of my content changed pretty significantly in 20 content and
the ins.
I think that mostly h I think that mostly happened with Omaha.
Uh I don't for I'm still listening. I have to let my dog out.
I just went way too far
Sure. I I'll I'll concede that it's
differentizations for the midterms or whatever. So like for inance
right now I'm not in school. There might be things I'm saying
or doing now that are going to that would severely hurt my ability
to um go to law school. So is he saying that this wouldn't hurt
his ability to go to anything else or something? I don't know
something. What are you What are you doing here, Archangel? Why
are you
Why are you dingdoning
like that? um the nature of my content changed pretty significantly
in 2024 in a way that I don't think I would have ever foreseen.
So I mean like part of the reasons why my personal life is now
a lot more again I try to keep this almost entirely away from
content discussions. I really don't care about the content and
I think Connor shouldn't care about the content either. The content
can be like a totally different argument. Probably it's the habitual
consent violations, the habitual trust and privacy violations
that make Destiny look bad here, right? Isn't that more what
it is? Like habitual consent and trust violations are the people
he should hold nearest and dearest? I think so. That that's like
more what it is. Hey, the people you should care about most in
the world, you don't care about their privacy, you don't care
about their security, you don't care about their consent, you
don't care about anything that do you think that will affect
your political projects going forward? not on stream as as a
result of the change of the content. But I don't I don't think
in 2023 or 20 or before that I don't think I would have seen
my content changing as significantly. So like does that does
the prior stuff potentially hamper me now? I mean to some extent
yeah probably but I mean it's I don't think I could have foresaw
that necessarily. Okay then I I would say uh this is something
that I c I catch flack for but I still believe it sincerely.
Yeah. Connor Connor just wants to say I told you so and like
I predicted this so I told you so. So, I'm going to state it
is that I view a lot of the pleasure- seeeking behaviors as correlated
with negative consequences. I think that I did not hear promiscuity.
I think that, you know, engaging with multiple partners, having
complex relationships, having relationships implode, uh that
might be fun for you. Maybe that's the way that you want to conduct
your relationships. But I often whenever I bump into somebody
who is either polyamorous, promiscuous, etc., etc., They always
seem to be reaping
incredibly difficult personal
Sure, that might be the case. Sure. I I don't know if that's
really due to the na the nature of those
themselves or if the types of people who have those relationships
are usually more immature. And that's what I found. I mean, even
usually the types of people with those relationships are very
immature. Yeah. Even if this was true, even if I grant all of
that, I mean, people have a right to make mistakes in life. People
have a right to regret things or do things that they otherwise
wouldn't want to do, like I think that's I think that's fine.
I think it's part of being an adult. I think it's part of being
a human. I don't think I would necessarily avoid or forgo something
entirely because people engage with it, some people end up regretting
things at the end or have a negative view at the end. I mean,
like assuming everybody's an adult. I mean, everybody can make
decisions like Yeah. So, so I I guess this is this is begging
the question then, uh, although I might be using that phrase
incorrectly. Uh, did you make mistakes in 2022 that you're not
going to make going forward?
So, I'd say like a general criticism of counterpoints here would
be I think your want to be correct about your prediction from
before is affecting your ability to effectively question Destiny
on his conduct and what exact like crystallize what exactly the
bad behavior is that people should want him not to be involved
in politics over hopefully. Definitionally, a mistake. What did
he say? Sorry. What did he say exactly in 2022? What was his
prediction? It was you're a it's just all the you're a degenerate
and this degenerate lifestyle leads to bad outcomes for everybody.
Okay. Yeah. Something you hope you don't make going forward,
right? Kind of like ABA, right? Yeah. Yep. So, is there are there
things that you did in the past that you're not going to repeat
going forward? Well, are you asking me if I made mistakes or
are you asking me if there's a lifestyle choice that I don't
want to repeat? Because these are different things. Because if
you're if you're Can I ask one? Can I ask one and then the other?
Sure. Did you Did you make mistakes? Of course. Yeah. I've made
mistakes every probably every single year of my life. I'm sure
I've made mistakes. Wow. That's Oh my god. He's just like me.
He makes mistakes, too. Is what
cognitively victims think there. They're like, "Whoa, he admitted
he made mistakes. Oh my god. He He admitted he made a mistake.
Oh my god. Oh my god." Okay. And then are you making lifestyle
choices that are different compared to 2022 compared to now?
Yeah, I am now for sure. But a lot of it, the majority of it
is just because my interests have dramatically changed. Not necessarily
because I thought that like living. Can you articulate how? Um,
I think I have a higher penant for like studying and being more
politically focused now. So, this is the stuff that's appealing
to me more. So, it's the primary direction of my content versus
Yeah, Kingler, I would just say probably what Connor should be
pressing him on here because what Connor's been pressed about
is Destiny actively seeking doxes, saying that he wants them
to dox people and then trying to encourage people to kill or
harm the people he has doxed and others actually. Right? That's
that's 2025 behavior. That's 2025 Destiny. That's Destiny 3 weeks
ago, right? So, that's that's what Connor should probably be
trying to press him about. I think they get there eventually,
but we'll see. Before, um, my interests were like much more varied,
so you'd see a much wider variety of stuff on my stream, basically.
How much do you how much do you associate this like change in
temperament and change in focus? How much do you associate it
with uh, medication?
Um, my guess is going to be pretty significantly, but I would
want to be careful because some people have like said this and
then some people like weaponized this as though Destiny said
that when he started taking vivance, now he hates or something.
I'll never have seen this again. Like, which is
uh Nobody said that. Literally, nobody has said that except Dan.
Okay. Dan was the one who's like, he's on Viveance. He's not
a Gooner anymore. Destiny has said that. Nobody Nobody has made
this argument that like, oh well, he said he would never have
again now that he's on V. Nobody said that. Everybody pretty
much everything everybody said was you're for even trying to
make that argument. You look insane.
Didn't like lots of at least logs drop of him being the same
since he was taking the Vance at least. Actually, multiple logs
dropped of him saying I I'm like so much hornier on Vance.
I was going to say the [__] Yeah, we were all meing
about how he looked saying this and nobody said what he said,
right? He does the hyperbole thing here again. He does the hyperbole
thing. He's just going to attack it, right? How much do you how
much do you associate this like change in gas is going to be
pretty significantly but I I would want to be careful because
some people have like said this and then some people like weaponized
this as though Destiny said that when he started taking vivance
now he hates sticks or something
nobody nobody ever said now that Destiny took Viveance he hates
that's a total straw man nobody said that or that he would never
have again nobody said that nobody nobody said that he was saying
that he has entirely fabricated this you can go through all of
my logs everything I've ever said. I have never once said that.
Right. Yeah. He's making a straw man of an argument that doesn't
exist. He's just being he's being hyperbolic. But when he does
it, actually doesn't mean
It might be worth um I'm not sure if Riyle or anyone else is
listening when he is saying contradictory things to bring up
the evidence of that contradiction. I can try and dig for some
of it, but like um yeah, just because I think it's really easy
for him to weasle away from things when he's not like immediately
um confronted with the evidence of the contrary, I guess. Sure.
I mean, we all know he's full of, but it is useful to have that
visual aid of, oh, look, here he is lying. It's just I don't
know. Yeah, sure. Yeah. So, hold on. I'll copy this into another
thing. Hold on.
Oh, have you got like a Google doc going? Uh, yeah. I'll just
I'll copy this time stamp and say uh I people say I said I wouldn't
have saved anymore anymore on Vance. Total hyperbole. Totally
made up. Totally insane. Um actual hallucinations on his part.
Um Yogi's in here trying to stroke him off digitally. It's amazing.
Um Yogi, why? Yo, Yog Yog is literally taking the hyperbole from
Destiny and slurping his [__] Okay. But when we do
hyperbole, Yogi loses his mind. It's amazing. Um I I have him
like muted in my in the chat I actually have on stream. It's
very funny, brother. Sex like which is not at all uh the implication
that anybody should take from that. Um but um I think basically
he said now that he takes VI Vance he's not interested in like
meaningless stuff in the same way. And I I don't know if anybody
ever basically the only way we engaged with this was to say,
"Hey,
actually, we just criticized that statement as insane." When
you and Dan tried to say, "Oh, you took Vance uh and now your
your proclivities have changed. Now that behavior doesn't exist
anymore, the the what would we call it? Like um the overtly degenerate
behavior. You were just lying." We're like, "Yeah, you're lying
about that." It wasn't us going, "Oh, he said that he would never
have sex again." No, we're just like, "You lied. you just like
openly lied about that. Also, what's more likely that the medication
made any effect at all or simply he has no hose anymore because
no who would be interested in him at this point? Like all of
your stuff will get leaked at any point. He's very intimidating
mean like where is the plus point of Destiny? He's not good-looking.
He's a short, fat, balding man. So, like why? You think you're
going to get clout from his cruel audience like of misogynists
that are left? You're going to have to have cripplingly low self-esteem.
I don't So, you're either ugly or there's something wrong with
you. I don't know. Sure. We have to find Yes, but he's cheap
as. So, why does I can explain to you guys where you can find
these clips. So, Dan said, "Oh, he's a gooner and he's on Viveance
now. He's all changed." And Destiny said, I believe in Russell
search something about Vivance and his his proclivities. Right.
Sorry. Why would this be a cope session? Kelly, are you saying
he's not short, fat, and losing his beard? Like, uh, where's
the cope? I'm sorry. Please do specify. Saying he's rich when
he's a cheap is kind of like, okay. Uh, here's him on the other
side.
But now anytime some random person DMs me or flirts and I reciprocate.
People are like, "Oh, I guess the Viveance didn't change anything
since this didn't fall off Lauo, like he's he's using um people
talking about this to for him saying no, Viveance obviously changed
my behavior, right?" But like this is not what anybody ever said.
It's like like, "Hey, you're totally going to interact with people
and have these conversations instantly, right?" Cuz that's that's
broadly what it was was you were having conversations with people
you didn't know and sending them sex tapes. You're like, "Oh,
that behavior changed. That won't be a risk anymore because of
vance." Yes, you you said that. You said that that specific degenerate
behavior was going to change. You weren't chasing secrets all
the time. Oh, okay. To the person that said girls married serial
killers. Okay. Sorry, I wasn't making that argument. Yes, there'll
still be lowquality hoes floating around. No one's arguing with
that. I agree. There's still going to be some incredibly mentally
ill people. Sorry, I shouldn't say mentally ill. I'm trying to
get out of the habit of using mental illness as an insult. There's
still going to be some very gutter trash that'll go near him.
Yes, I agree. The way I just described the way I just described
is exactly what he says here. Just made me lose interest and
is as aggressively pursuing some hookup stuff and got me more
focused on work. That's what I said. He said he's going I don't
know who he's arguing with. I don't know who said any of this
stuff. Oh, sure. The empath chan stuff. Yeah. And then like for
crackheads. Yes. It's just like that's probably not true. He
probably didn't change that much in terms of he changed how public
the behavior was. That's what changed. It's fine. It's more just
like the style of content or the stuff that I enjoy pursuing
on stream is much more focused now on on politics. Hang on a
second. Before it was a lot. This is not hating on women. All
right. If you're a man and you hate on the 10% of lowest like
gutter trash men, you're not hating men. You're hating a small
percentage of that gender that suck. Okay. That's the same with
this concept. Yes. Okay. Not broadly hating women. I don't I
don't need to attach myself to any of Kelly's opinions. Kelly's
opinions are her own. I'm not listening to what she's saying
in that regard. Sure. They are my opinions. Is your opinion that
much different? I'm not even talking about it because I don't
focus on other people to talk about them. It's just not something
I'm interested in. So, okay. I'm just
I'm not broadly hating women. I don't think most women would
go anywhere near him, so it's not really a problem. Okay. More
varied. Okay. Then uh I do want to move into I I think we covered
the majority of what it was. So effectively like I would describe
you as a hedenist. I would describe you as a nihilist. I think
you confirmed that to some higher level degree. Uh I think that
vegan gains has contentions with the way that I'm using definitionally
and the moral implications that I'm associating with those words.
I don't care about the definitions or anything. It's fine. As
long as I understand what you're saying and we can have the same
conversation, that's fine. I don't care. It's all good. Well,
and I'm trying to summarize to move into the the next segment,
which I think is important. Uh so, uh and then you kind of isolated
prescriptive moral duties versus pleasure- seeeking, and you
don't see the at least in my opinion, what you said is that you
don't see these as necessarily in conflict. Just because you
have pleasure- seeeking in a certain aspect of your life doesn't
mean that you're not capable of carrying out your higher prescriptive
moral duties. Yeah, of course. I would say that for sure. Everybody
would agree with that to some extent. You just have to figure
out where to draw the line, right? Vegan Gains still talks to
Destiny. I mean, yeah, Vegan Gains, no, Vegan Gains was always
on Destiny's side, right? So, something that I that I that I
bumped into or probably the thing that's most contentious within
the past couple of months is obviously all the drama getting
revealed, but then with some of your your critics, what they've
held on to is uh I believe uh you know, you can correct me at
any point, but you called for their docs and then also said that
and then published your own niche docs of people, not either
of us apparently, but he literally published docs in his own
chat. him himself, right? It's not it's not he just sought docs.
He literally sought them out, sought them out, said, "No, they're
not for a lawsuit. They're to dox these people and then tried
to dox those people and then directed death threats or uh uh
actually said, I want somebody to kill these people." So, that
you kind of wish some of them would die. So, could you elaborate
on some of that? Yeah. So, one thing that and everybody plays
stupid with this. All the people involved play stupid with this.
Um there's this very interest I I'll just go ahead and like engage
with literally everything he says phenomenon set up where especially
for smaller creators what they do is they'll have these like
attack dog communities that all of them constantly reference
and participate in and they either the lead creators themselves
don't do it or um or their community in particular doesn't do
it but they'll know that there's a ton of interflow between them
and another community. So, so he's basically saying that regardless
of my will, the idea that Kiwi Farms hates him means that me
hating on him is actually something that he can blame me for
all of Kiwi Farm's actions. That's the logic train he's setting
up here, right? Really? Like that is unironically the logic train
he's setting up. Think about all of his arguments, right? Think
about all of his arguments that he ever did against Keels and
[__] where people were like where he was like, "Oh,
you can't blame harassment on my community. Why would you be
able to do that? Show me where that's happening in my community,
right? That's unironically he made these arguments for like a
year and a half during the Keles arc. It's insane that he would
now go to this. He's like, "Yeah, actually, even if even if the
leader, he's talking about me there, right? The leader Jtock
doesn't do this or doesn't support it. He knows that it's happening
somewhere around."
Oh, what? What? Sorry. Who are you leading? Apparently, well,
I assume he means that I own the Discord. I assume that's what
he means. By the way, a discord built on a discord built purely
from fans of his originally, right? They do is they'll have these
like attack dog communities that all of them constantly reference
and participate in and they either the lead creators themselves
don't do it or um or their community in particular doesn't do
it, but they'll know that there's a ton of interflow between
them and another community that they more or less support um
sometimes openly by quoting their stuff constantly and then laughing.
Uh, so Destiny apparently is saying here that you are responsible
for all of Kiwi Farms's actions, everything that happens on Kiwi
Farms if you use information from Kiwi Farms. Destiny being the
person who quoted Kiwi Farms a in uh he quoted Kiwi Farms a in
his Keels manifesto. Destiny who said I'm going to support monetarily
Kiwi Farms in respect to their lawsuit against Keels, any potential
litigation against Keffles. Destiny who participated in registered
on Kiwi Farms participated in his own thread after revenge of
him was posted on there. Okay. After right so everything he has
said here is totally insane. I would expect Connor to point out
like hey literally all of these things apply to you and have
applied to you for years before this ever happened. Yes. this
all of these behaviors you're describing are behaviors you have
engaged in yourself multiple times way more than anybody else
that you are talking about or could possibly talk about here
that's the question I would expect from Connor here right so
this is where he is hold on let me throw this in the dock over
here um this is complaining about kiwi farms or people adjacent
he made an entire document that was basically sourced from or
used kiwi farms as a primary source for like thing right now.
My argument on Kiwi Farms, which has never changed, is if they're
if they're just posting a clip of Destiny speaking and I get
it from there, I don't care. Right? As a as a source of primary
information, as an archival source of primary information, I'll
use it. Right? If you are just giving me Destiny's words verbatim,
if you are just taking an archive of Destiny's words from YouTube
or from his chat, I'll just use those because there's no docs
information there. If that makes you upset that I will use that,
I don't know what to tell you. Everything else that comes from
primary information that I had first. He he talks about me trying
to reference Kiwi Farms. Kiwi Farms watches my stream and they
talk about things I say. You're not going to debate your way
out of vengeance. What What What does any of this have to do
with me disliking Destiny? You're If you're saying that I don't
hate Destiny. Obviously, I hate Destiny. What are you talking
about? I'm saying that I basically have a policy in my Discord.
Don't link uh pictures from Kiwi Farms, right? Don't link pictures.
Don't link like [__] Don't reference it. I think
we even have a don't referenc it policy and I have to look for
sure but I know that we delete if you put if you put a screenshot
from Kiwi Farms in my discord that gets deleted. Yes. But what
I will say is it's fairly obvious he was going to go down this
line of argumentation even though he's the person that probably
mentions Queen Kiwi Farms more than anyone else when he's complaining
especially in DGG. So it's like yes
ah I don't know Douggee Chan I'll just point out your cognitive
one more time. You took me saying that I don't support Kiwi Farms,
doxing anybody, harassing people. I don't support anything done
from that site that is outside of my ethics, right? But you are
a cognitive victim. So you took that as me saying I don't hate
Destiny. Do you see the dissonance happening there? Do you understand
the dissonance happening there? Can you see it and identify?
I just want you to know, okay, that's your you don't have critical
thinking capability. You need to stop watching Destiny and watch
something else so you can regain your inner monologue and no
longer be an NPC. Just letting you know. I want to point out
there's also several degrees of separation between simply talking
about Kiwi Farms and I directly somehow linking to the revenge
born for example. I don't think you can even do that now cuz
you requires making an account on the website. But also if you
live in Britain you can't even access Kiwi farmers anymore cuz
uh for some strange reason like that's going to get people in
trouble. I'm not sure, but whatever. And beyond that, it's not
on the front pages of any of the things that they're talking
about, right? So, it's like you'd have to go what sort of four
steps beyond someone simply mentioning it to find any of this
type of material. So, it's just really disingenuous to suggest
that's what anyone is doing when they're mentioning something
that's been referenced there. Um, I mean, it would depend on
how hard it was to find, right? I would say directing towards
Anna's Kiwi Farms thread in my opinion when there's like two
pages and one of those pages is her docs is probably a insane
thing to do and then to say well I wasn't I wasn't amplifying
her docs or anything guys so it would depend um I think you could
talk about it. I think it's unfortunate that it like that stuff
like this exists. I it sucks. I don't want anybody around Destiny
docs. I disavow anybody doxing somebody around Destiny. I disavow
any collateral damage. I've done it repeatedly on my stream all
the time. I also think doxing is bad and I'm very glad that I
have moved and I'm just not telling anyone where I live, including
my parents or taking any pictures here. So, cuz I value my safety.
You kind of wish some of them would die. So, could you elaborate
on some of that? Start over again. One thing that and everybody
plays stupid with this. All the people involved play stupid with
this. Um there's this very interesting phenomenon set up where
especially for smaller creators, what they do is they'll have
these like attack dog communities that all of them constantly
reference and participate in and they either the lead creators
themselves don't do it or um or their community in particular
doesn't do it, but they'll know that there's a ton of interflow
between them and another community that they more or less support
um sometimes openly by quoting their stuff. So am I am I supposed
to somehow prevent people from taking screenshots of my Discord?
How how how am I supposed to do that? I I'm super confused constantly
and then laughing about it or sometimes a little bit more covertly
like uh there's one cognitive victim in chat who is arguing well
your name's referenced in the thread a lot and your clips are
in the thread a lot and I'm like okay Destiny's name is referenced
in the thread a lot and it clips are in the thread a lot uh what
what are we Hello can I can I get somebody I I wish we had anybody
who was int but there aren't intelligent people who will argue
Destiny's side so it falls apart
at this point sorry at this point after everything he's done
to you. So, not just the attempting to dox and the people around
you attempting to dox, but also the death threats. Should we
at this point care about mentioning kiwi farms? Yes. Like, how
does the things No, you're better than him. Oh, so we shouldn't
be mentioning kiwi farms at all. Well, we have been
Sorry, but I think I think talking about things from there that
you are finding from there, I I would just leave it off of there
if it's being used to harass somebody. Okay. But that's a bit
of a
If you found something on there and you're using it to harass
somebody and you found it from there, I would probably not do
it. I would disagree with that. But haven't we found out a lot
of information about what Destiny has been doing from there?
Nope. Yes, we have. Because all of those um some of the women
that he was talking to after Viveance and specifically about
Viveance, the stuff was posted on there and that's how I know
about it. Okay. I I have essentially all information that I have
I have from like primary sources. So I mean you do have primary
sources too. That's true. But a lot of things that we have found
out we found out first from Kiwi farmers. There sure is a lot
of content of yours in that thread though. There's a lot of content
from a lot of people. I'm critical of him. I would expect if
I make a good argument, somebody who hates Destiny would clip
that argument and put it in the thread. That is an unless you
can tell me how I am harassing Destiny or how my content is like
trying to hurt the people around him. you're it is a public stream.
People can comment on it, clip it however they like very obviously.
No. Anyway, I uh we should focus on moving forward. Actually
pass information off to and from some of these people. Um for
people that are involved in that and then for those community,
he even says, "Oh, I think somebody probably passes that could
happen. I don't know. How the could I possibly be responsible
for that? In what universe could you hold me responsible for
that? Is that not insane? Can anyone explain to me how that wouldn't
be [__] nuts? Also, I don't I don't understand how
you think I'm making the DOS kid argument. That's not what I'm
doing. Also, threatening to kill people and he did some pretty
extreme things. He said some pretty extreme things to this kid.
Yeah, that's that's quite different. People is, you know, it's
not just uh immoral, it's illegal and has serious consequences.
I don't whereas talking about kiwi farms is I don't even think
immoral necessarily. It depends on what you're talking about.
That are doxing and attacking people around me in like overt
ways which they do and you can see that like very openly. Um
I have absolutely zero regard for those people. I literally have
no regard for them. I think that they're the worst most cowardly
types of people. Uh so he has gone from Okay, I just want you
to follow this. I have no regard for those people. Connor really
needs to say, "Okay, but you you called for their docs. You received
their you received what was purported to be their docs and then
you doxed them. You you literally published that information
as soon as you could and then you said you want people to kill
them." So like you've gone from apparently there's eight links
in this chain. There's like Kiwi Farms who have like people on
Kiwi Farms who have like doxed people around Destiny and he's
gone to from there well there are people who read Kiwi Farms
who exist in Jtocks Discord and even though the policy there
is you can't you you can't post links to there you can't post
screenshots from there right even though that's the policy don't
talk about that place is broadly what's suggested right I don't
know if you I don't know if people get banned for it if repeated
violations would get you banned but it's just like hey no we're
not doing that right so even though that's the policy I actually
blame Jtock even though he directed his mods to enact that policy.
I actually blame Jtock despite that and I think there might be
people who also post on Kiwi Farms somewhere around there. Right.
So I actually blame I blame Jtock and beyond that he also called
for the death of Quean and Queman he he published docs he says
are of Quean. Quean is not he doesn't own my discord. Where the
do you jump to there? Yeah, he just uh really doesn't like Quman.
Can anybody explain how in the world we've done these jumps?
Spicy chat is connected with Kiwi forms. Quan is not Chad Logic.
Quan is not a mod in spicy chat. What are you How are you How
do you web things so hard like this? You need to go through like
it's not even like standard webbing of like some people around
here. It's not even webbing. It's like it's like ret it's just
the most [__] I've ever heard. And I would love if
Connor had uh called him out on this that like hey do you think
it's appropriate to say well I suspect that there are some chatters
who like screenshot from Jox Discord and might post it on KF.
I I think because of that even though it's broadly against the
rules you're not allowed to do it and if I could report somebody
they'd probably ban that person. Actually despite all of that
um I'm still going to hold everybody else responsible. Isn't
that insane? Didn't a bunch of DJers think I was insane for trying
to hold Dan to that standard and saying if you don't stop the
juice doctor [__] like I'm going to publish it about
you. Wasn't I the one who was told they were insane for literally
one one degree of separation on the Dan stuff, right? Jesus.
Yeah. Also, um, there's a there's a number of users that have
been attempting to a log whatever they do to Destiny for years.
Is he just trying to imply that somehow existence influences
that they're well known to him? That's a great point. One of
the people who who does dox people around Destiny actually started
doing that before I even streamed. What? What are we doing? They
did that before I streamed. The guy was trying to dox me and
shelf owner and like a bunch of other people in the group. Like
the idea that we're like, "Oh yeah, they're our buddies now."
People that were doxing us six months ago. How am I being held
responsible for this person's actions? I'm just baffled. These
are like people that have been following him for a long time.
They've been posting for a long time. It's just like I don't
know. Chief, like you think this 500 viewer streamer is like
detrimental to what goes on on Kiwi Farms as well. It's just
like no offense, bro, but what? I don't It's crazy. Uh yeah.
And that's Yeah. And And so if I was to try to explain that,
you know, back I guess. So you're saying that the drama farm
communities that are effectively like they've latched on to the
drama of November, they've latched on to the release of the drama
in February, and they continue to make it central to their content.
Now in April, you're uh you're accusing them of playing dumb
uh when they're getting their information from websites uh doxing
websites or Kiwi Farms is obviously the biggest example. You're
saying that they're playing dumb when they're playing footsy
with I do not get most of my information from Kiwi Farms is just
what I would say. Um I will pull logs of Destiny from there.
And again, I've said this multiple times, it's just cuz somebody
goes out of their way to format it nicely, right? They go to
like the pullcat combo thing and they pull the logs from there.
That's where I pull my information from. Or sorry, that's where
I pull Destiny information from. Destiny logs from. Destiny needs
to stop hating on Kiwi Farms as a source when he relies on Wikipedia.
Okay. If you're going to hate on secondary sources, then I want
to see him never use secondary sources himself.
Like you can simply check a source on a website like Kiwi Farms
or Wikipedia, whatever to see if the information is true or good,
but that's all you're obligated to do. That doesn't mean that
those sources are bad. Jesus, they're like I can't even tell
if like the people in chat are like overt. I It's actually It's
hard to tell. Anyway, did I say Wikipedia is Kiwi? I broadly
don't I broadly don't agree or understand that argument, but
go ahead. Um, that's I I'm saying I didn't follow just because
just because the information on Kiwi Farms is on Kiwi Farms doesn't
mean it's untrue. Yes.
Uh, sure. And you can just simply fact check it. Yes.
Sure. Yeah. Then that would be the same way that you treat Wikipedia.
Yes. Broadly, whenever you're looking for a source, you're supposed
to check the source cuz Wikipedia is just a collection of sources.
Yes. Uh, I see where this could come from. Possibly. Pensive
goat. the idea that the uh leaked call or whatever that that
would be no that was um that was something I had heard long before
KF or or that was public.
Um, actually, fun fact, the reason I thought there were two different
instances of the gay, right, uh, of the gay recording when I
had that first conversation with Darius was because I knew about
one of them was that I' I'd heard the beginning of that one,
right? Somebody had sent me that and said, "Hey, it sounds like
this was recorded non-conensually." And so I had it in my head
as two and then I said to without realizing those screenshots
were of the same event, right? That's very funny. I did not say
Kiwi Farms is real. No, please don't please don't engage with
retards. He he doesn't understand. Make him tell him to just
go back and relist to what you said. Um because he's
I need you to Google what is a secondary source. Wikipedia is
a secondary source, not a primary source. If you don't know what
secondary sources are, I'm going to need you to Google it. Okay,
buddy. All right, good job. Okay, so what Kelly is saying is
that basically you can find information on any source and then
if that information is true then why shouldn't I repeat it? Um,
broadly for factual stuff I would say I don't really care. It
would depend on what it is and how it's being used. Uh, like
obviously broadly for like facts that are relevant to something
public that aren't going to put somebody in danger maybe. But
then like obviously you get to like doc stuff which is docs are
true. Is there reason you wouldn't want to report those? Yeah.
So you'd have to do a lot more thinking to come to a coherent
position there. I don't know broadly where you're trying to go
with the Wikipedia. Like I don't understand it. So I don't you
can go ahead and go off on that point. I want to continue cuz
I don't want to get bogged down in that whole thing. So you could
argue in chat if you want to argue with people in chat about
you understand what a secondary sources versus a primary source.
Yes.
Wikipedia is simply a collection of other sources. It's a compilation.
So it's not a primary source. Yes. That's all my argument is.
Kiwi Farms would be similar. Is it as reliable? No, because it's
not like edited by as many people or observed by as many people.
The bar of quality is lower. So, no, they're not the same with
that community while that community is harassing. A uh I would
say probably a reason you couldn't compare them is Wikipedia's
open source and like um the information is only in one page there
and people have to broadly agree. in KF it's like a lot of skits
posting theories and stuff is very different in that way but
I yeah I mean little bit um I like I don't I don't want sorry
I don't want to have any rebuttal or anything be more clear here
although at the end of the day this doesn't matter because everybody
wants to weaponize this on both sides um and they should bother
you if you're a critic of mine actually for some of these people
it does bother them and I've seen them say as much
um people have a very hard time criticizing somebody for uh making
a mistake or doing something bad or being bad or whatever without
going way overboard. So, I don't like the term Oh, no. Hyperbole.
Hyperbole. He's engaged in hyperbole like a thousand times in
this conversation, just like I did right there. He's done it
at least three or four times, and now he's going to go, "Oh,
these people can't discuss my habitual consent violations without
getting hyperbolic." Oh my god. They can't discuss my habitual
uh consent violations without getting really hyperbolic about
it. Sometimes they compare my consent violations to a digital
form of rap. And I didn't rape anybody actually. Uh I I just
recorded them non-consensually and then distributed those recordings
non-consensually. I didn't rape anybody. It's so different. Digital.
That's
crazy. Like centered on my drama or weaponizing my drama because
like there are things that you can legitimately criticize me
for. Um and if you want to criticize me for those things or if
you want to talk about news or whatever related to those things,
I think it's for the most part I think it's fair game, right?
I'm a public figure. There's stuff that's posted publicly about
me. I talk about something public. I think it's fair game, but
when those same communities are actively and aggressively trying
to dox every single person in my or so again, he's going to So
he he talks, okay, I would love to see where I'm not mostly 95%
just reporting factually on things. Okay, but then he's going
to try to web again the people criticizing him who are doing
the thing he just said that it should be okay, right? He's going
to try to web them in with Kiwi farms, which is insane. Bit
waited publicly about me. I The entire purpose of this conversation
is to ask why did you try to dox people? Why did you direct death
threats at people? Why did you try to say that these people need
to be killed? You want them killed. Why did you publish information
that could lead to them being found? So you say, right, and then
say, "Well, I wouldn't do that unless I wanted them killed."
And then say, "Yeah, I do want them killed." What? Why? That's
the topic of conversation right now is why did you do that? So
him saying this is about kiwi farms, it doesn't make any sense.
I talk about something. It it only makes sense in a world where
you've tried to tie the people you want killed in with kiwi farms
so you can justify them being killed. And he's going to repeatedly
justify the statements wanting people killed. It's what he's
doing right now. He's trying to justify calling for violence
against people. Never once has he said, "Oh, I'm actually being
hyperbolic and I was just joking. I don't actually want them
killed." No, he's just repeatedly justified wanting these people
killed. Something I think it's fair game, but when those same
communities are actively and aggressively trying to dox every
single person in my orbit that is trying to or that like ostensibly
appears to be like on my side. Now you've crossed into a really
disgusting world I think. So like two exact examples that I can
give of this I think is insane. So there's a girl that I That's
actually literally what I was going to ask for was two exact
So two things that I think were very interesting. So, um, so
he's supposed to be giving examples of the people around him
getting doxed. I hate giving names saying to these people because
I know it fuels them cuz they just they get off on my attention
cuz I'm their daddy. But, um, there was a girl called Zoe. Met
her for a while. We were cool um for a long time. She was a super
normie person. Like didn't even have a disc. What? Oh, you can
still hear me? Yeah. I'm sorry. The dog dogs and they keep wanting
I don't think many normie people come to find him. But he's going
to talk about Zoe now. I don't know what Zoe's done specifically.
Go for it. We'll see if he represents this accurately. Yeah.
Person I know, I shouldn't even use their name or whatever, but
person I know seems like a pretty normal chill person or whatever.
Um, we chat for a while, we meet up, everything's cool. This
person as a result of being close to me, right, or or as a result
of being my friend, there are people on another website that
like docks this person and docks her eventually her boyfriend.
Uh, this was a function of you getting her into my Discord and
then her participating in content on my Discord that upset some
skitso. Apparently, we're supposed to we're literally supposed
to just go ahead and say, "Okay, any content around Destiny that
this guy decides to dox somebody over." That's like directly
the fault of I the content. I don't even know. I don't know where
these two people have to literally leave uh in fear. Uh everybody's
against this by the way. And I by the way, I talked to both Jacob
and Zoe. Literally, they asked, "Hey, could you delete our logs
and like never mention us again." I was like, "Yeah, for sure.
Like, I understand and I'm so sorry this happened to you and
like yeah, I'll we don't have to like talk about you at all."
Right.
Yeah, that's exactly because of the the doces that are posted
to them, Jacob and and Zoe. Um, and the only reason explicitly
why they are doxed is because the person says, "These are Destiny's
friends. I hate that they support him. So, I'm doxing these people,
right?" And these people leave and then I don't actually know
what happens. I guess they spent a lot of time in the in the
district server, whatever. Eventually become like my
Oh, no. What happened was I think Zoe was sent non-consensual
content.
Zoe was sent non-consensual and she was like, "Oh, this guy's
really bad." And then she joined my Discord way after the fact.
That's what made Jacob and Zoe turn against him was Zoe went,
"Oh, holy [__] This guy sent me a bunch of stuff
non-consensually. That's really [__] crazy. Oh, he's
actually a total piece of shit." They were gone for quite a long
time because of that doxing, right? They were just like not active
like in any Discords for months after that. And then he's acting
like people wouldn't be affected by him committing crimes and
involving them in it. It's like, yeah, no, she doesn't like you,
you freak. I wouldn't like you if you did that to me either.
Fun fact, one of the people before I knew who it was, one of
the people who made an anonymous account to reach out to me to
say, "Hey, I was sent this stuff non-consensually
was Zoe." And I didn't know who it was cuz she didn't want to
be involved in any of these communities at all. That was one
of the people who reached out originally. It was like, "Hey,
here's other examples of non-consensual things. I sent this and
this and this, right?" Not files, by the way, just describing.
And then I Yeah. So, I'm saying, and I verified this by getting
people to basically I'd find the victim of one of these things.
And I'd say, "Hey, is this you?" And they they would trade the
file. It would be them, right? Or like some of them were obviously
like visible. That this didn't happen with Zoe necessarily. I'm
just saying that like like it's literally Zoe was not in my Discord.
Zoe reached out to me originally on an anonymous account to say,
"Hey, I was given um like non-consensual materials." It's just
I'm just baffled. It's just okay. The fact that he just like
glosses over there like, "Oh, I just can't understand why they
wouldn't like me anymore." It's like, yeah, some people don't
like you committed crimes. Are you just like baffled by this
that you can't possibly understand how anyone could have a stance
where they might dislike you and not only that, but you involved
them in them? It's just like hello. Oh, hold on. Stephen Jian
says, "Wait, Jaytock, don't bite my head off, but did you have
proof he was breaking people's consent before Destiny's leaks
came out?" Like, uh, you had the gay recording or even more?
No, that was after the leaks came out. Um, I didn't have any
of the element of that. I just had the non-consentual part. But,
um, uh, so to answer your question, I had an assumption that
he didn't have Pixie's consent, but I had sort of coped my way
in the cognitively rigged way that they do, that most DJs do.
I kind of coped my way into saying, "Well, I don't really know
for sure." uh before before the Pixie stuff came out, I said,
"No, no, no, sorry. Before um before the January 20th, I did
say that like I think if I had to bet money, he non-consensually
uh sent around of people, right?" Like a balance of probability.
Yeah. Non-conensually is how he distributed these things. Yeah.
Anyway, um and the only reason explicitly why they are doxed
is because the person says, "These are Destiny's friends. I hate
that they support him. So, I'm doxing these people, right?" And
these people leave and then I don't actually know what happens.
I guess they spent a lot of time in the in the district. So he
just made this up. Holcloth. I think this has been corrected
for him actually. I think we had the Darius stream where he talked
about Zoe and I think this is corrected for him. So he is just
knowingly lying here. I think he's just knowingly lying that
he that I think this has been like fixed. This misunderstanding
of his has been fixed. He's just knowingly lying because he's
got the bigger platform
server, whatever. eventually become like my number one of all
of his demented lies cuz there's been quite a lot at this point.
It's just I don't think he cares anymore. He's just happy to
just straight up like say the vilest because like no one's big
enough to like do anything about it and he can just intimidate
everybody.
I don't know. It's insane. Uh time stamp lies about how Zoe came
back to Jtock Discord. It really is a cult. Actually know what
happens. I guess they spend a lot of time. And another thing,
there are more like DGers that we know of because they use the
same names signed on to Kiwi Farms than there are anybody within
any like communities we know of. Right. I did find it really
funny that the sock who used to argue on Destiny's behalf ended
up becoming an anti-an because of him arguing on Destiny's behalf
and then Destiny repeatedly like violated. He like he was one
of the guys who's arguing like no he asked for docs cuz like
he just wants to serve papers or something and there was also
logs of him from the from the Darius Discord where he's like
it's so hard to actually um it's so hard to actually defend Destiny
because he keeps undermining the things I'm saying. Oh, people
on Q farms use existing names to treat people. Oh, could be.
Could be. Uh maybe that guy's not maybe Hey, maybe not. I just
that's a really like specific name to use and he uses the same
avatar. as possible. Also, that jelly bean can girl who was kind
of insane
from his community joined up to like defend him for a while.
Sure. Anyway, I'm in the the logistical server, whatever. Eventually
become like my number one haters like at all points in time.
They're talking about me constantly. Now, the they don't like
you because you are a degenerate who shares people's without
their consent. Actually, the fun fact is Zoe literally said,
"I would I'd take a video from you if it's consensually shared."
That was actually the caveat she threw into the logs. Hey, if
if listen, if the person consented that you're sharing it from,
then yeah, sure. Send me a video. That's, by the way, I'm pretty
sure Zoe leaked that. I'm pretty sure uh that's out there. It's
literally It's literally out there. It's It's out there. I don't
like Okay. Person that doxed them says, "Oh, I'm not doxing these
people. They're chill." Uh, now the girl herself says, "Oh, yeah,
like me and uh this guy." I mean, he'd already done it. He said,
"Oh, I wish I could take it back." And yeah, I I think basically
realizing that you're a total piece of [__] changed
people's minds. Shocker. We're cool now. Like, he's not going
to dox me. Meanwhile, um I remember uh he'd already doxed them.
He'd already doxed them. The I I think the quote was uh I wish
I could take back the doxing of them. The the docks had already
happened, Tom. Oh, by the way, by the way, it's very interesting
that Destiny's up on his high horse about this. Because really
all all they've done, all Zoe did was she came back. She was
like, "Hey, I have like I this I can see that this guy's a total
piece of [__] now. I didn't want to be a part of
this. He made me a part of it. Makes me feel disgusted." She
came back and then he started directing people towards their
docs on KF again. He's done it multiple times. We could pull
his logs. It's literally in his logs, right? Him directing people
repeatedly to Jacob's docs to uh Oh, yeah. Yeah. This
one. It's this guy. How am I supposed to defend this [__]
This isn't a There isn't a job on this planet more difficult
than sweeping for destiny. Like, he's actually just a psychopath,
right? It's impossible.
Hold them. Like, I trust. Oh, sure. My favorite part is where
he just links to like Queenman's obituary on Facebook. Like,
ah, yeah. This is his doc. It's a dead guy. Special me. Thank
you for the five months. Destiny docs. Where's this one? If someone
is bored, please relink Jacob's doc. So, Destiny is inviting
people. Please link the Kiwi Farms thread and the specific page
where Jacob's docs is. Please relink Jacob's docs. Guys, can
you dox this guy again? Please dox this guy again. Please dox
him. Oh my god. Please dox him. Wait, there's no way. Hold on.
There's no way that this is Wait, what? Is this a joke? Maybe
this is a joke I don't understand. If someone is bored, please
relink Jacob's docs. I am not linking your docs. If if someone
is bored, please reink Jacob's docs. 14 minutes. Sorry, 12 minutes
later. I am not linking your docs. What? This is the guy. This
is This is your This is your Yogi. This is your name. What are
you doing? Although, this could be some other joke cuz I am just
searching the word docs. Maybe Maybe there's something else going
on there. I have no idea. But yeah, weird. But he also said stuff
about Zoe, too.
Uh, hold on. I really do think he should at least give up on
trying to intimidate British people because it is clearly not
working and just
making even more embarrassing every day. He was threatening to
leak more, I guess, personal information about Zoe and Jacob
at some point. He's now kind of like run his gamut. He can't
do it anymore and we're still here. So, uh, what else did he
do? Um, he gave enough info away for him, Zoe, to be do to be
fully doxed by Kiwi Farm. So he he clearly has no problem with
Kiwi Farms doxing people so long as he can use those docks against
those people, right? When I do it, it's based and good. When
they do it, it's bad. I just don't understand. Like he's literally
he literally has argued basically that he I would never argue
this, but he has argued that he deserves to get hurt, right?
Like basically all of the behaviors he said that are a reason
for him to want somebody dead, he has engaged in 10 times more
than anybody else around me. Oh, this is also a lie, too. Convince
Cherry she was violated or something. This is just also a lie.
Uh Zoe didn't even talk to anyone here until after Cherry and
Pixie's posts were made. So, he just like he just lies repeatedly
over and over again, but no DGER cares to hold him to any of
the lies. Like the repeated lies over and over and over again.
Um he'll just lie in any way he can whenever he can to try to
shape the narrative back in his favor. It's embarrassing.
Yep. Like apparently I leaked his revenge in a Discord server
I made with Lav. We love that one. That was also great. That
was also a lot. That was brilliant. Peak. Hold on. Apparently
apparently this is another clip that is uh maybe good. We'll
see. As an adult, you have to at some point respond, but keeping
it to say about Oh, wait. This is uh this is him. His reaction
to people calling for violence character physically is great.
I mean, listen, all I'm saying is on site, you know, we all have
different ways that we react.
you know, so I'm not saying it's on site if I see Destiny at
TwitchCon again. I'm just saying, you know, it probably wouldn't
be on site, honestly. And it's so it's so cringe to call for
violence against people on the internet, isn't it? I think I'll
have I need to have a larger conversation about tomorrow. I'm
inspired by the Israeli, okay, is a concept of like deterrence.
I think that people I feel like if people are willing to make
comments like this online, that's fine, but I think they should
be afraid to do so. And I don't know if that's something I want
to engage in. this is like extreme online tactics or whatever.
But um I'm deeply uncomfortable with the idea that like multiple
people are feel safe and secure in essentially making like threats
of physical violence about me on platforms that are like harboring
it. Um that's this is like a wild that is actually uh that is
actually crazy. Wow. I I really feel like it's crazy that YouTube
continues to harbor this continued justification for calls to
violence by Destiny. Isn't it crazy? I feel like that's pretty
crazy. I feel like it's crazy. Listen, I would never I would
never advocate anything. Okay, leave Destiny alone. But isn't
it crazy that YouTube monetizes somebody who will repeatedly
over and over again justify their wanting death threats, their
wanting uh pushing to violence of their audience? Isn't that
crazy? That's crazy that YouTube will will go ahead and monetize
that content. I think that's just weird. Personally, not that
I would ever advocate you guys doing anything about that, but
like, yeah, it's really crazy that this guy will go and consistently
one make uh make overt calls to violence. I want these people
dead. I want someone to go kill these people. They're quoting
Destiny, right? And then he will justify that those statements
over and over and over again. I think that's very weird personally
that YouTube avows that and monetizes that. But oh boy, I don't
know if I could do anything about it, guys. My hands are kind
of tied. I don't really believe in reporting or anything. foolery
tweeted out something that was critical of something Pixie was
saying on Twitter and as soon as he made that one, it was like
the softest tweet. He's like, "Oh, I don't know about this particular
thing." His tweet gets posted immediately on the other website
and they're like, "Who is this Tom guy? Does anybody have his
docs? Can we find his information?" And now there's like this
pattern of if anybody hasn't explicitly separated from me, they're
targeted by these other communities. And as long as they're getting
any type of response or feedback, they're just going as hard
as they can until they can break that person off of me. and a
ton of people in say so like justical server is a good example
of this where these people do it a really great example of this
was uh Kelly um who I think is permanently banned on I was going
to make a comment on the he's accusing us of trying to isolate
people from him I disagree I don't think it's anybody or not
us Kiwi Farms maybe trying to isolate people from him I think
that a lot of people aren't aware of just how much he's done
I obviously none of like advocate for the doxing and stuff. So,
it just it just comes off as really disingenuous to be like,
"Oh, yeah, we're trying to isolate people from him." Yeah. I
don't even know what that means. He just constantly weaves between
Kiwi Farms and everybody else because he's using it as a justification
to call for death threats to to basically call for people to
report, for people to do whatever they can. There's been a mass
flagging campaign against my Discord for weeks now, right, based
on him trying to harass. I'm just saying. Yes. And also it's
it's a way to sort of control things from his end, right? Be
like, "Oh, you shouldn't say anything about any and criticize
any of the people around me because that's you trying to isolate
them from me and trying to make them like scared and run away
when you're the ones that is doing the intimidation tactics on
people." Like, who are we intimidating? And what proof do you
have that we've intimidated anybody? We're not. But that we've
had like healthy criticism as far as I'm concerned. Okay. Some
of the comments about Eridote are a bit weird, but they're still
they're not like intimidation
levels. Like I don't think she's scared because some people in
this Discord say she has greasy hair. Like I don't think she's
worried for her life.
Hold on. The doctors that are posting them, Jacob and and Zoe,
basically doxer, although she'll say it didn't count as doxing.
She was just linking separate accounts online. and they're running
for feedback. They're just going as hard as they can until they
can break that person off of me. And a ton of people in So, we
talked about the Tom Fery dogs. Um, by the way, I think broadly
it seems like to me regardless of Queen existing, me existing,
any of these streams existing, it seems more way more likely
to me that people who sorry, who defend Destiny, who destiny,
who defend Destiny in completely ways, those are the people who
like get attacked. I'm sorry. If you don't have like good arguments,
you're probably going to get attacked. Stop making repeated statements
in defense of destiny and you probably would be okay. Say so
like just like like literally if you made if you make good arguments
in defense that would be like by the way you shouldn't get attacked.
You should be allowed to be right. You should totally be allowed
to be. I disavow anybody who attacks these people for being okay
in terms of like going after their personal life in any way.
Going after any anything like that like doxing them. That's nuts.
But I'm saying that like to say it's like my fault. I don't even
know if I covered the Tom comments. I might have. I can't remember
it. Right. But like it's I'm saying that the attribution for
that is not on me. It's not my coverage that's pushing people
to go and do that. That is not what's happening there.
A good example of this quickly. I'm not perma banned on Discord.
It's a suspension. Okay. And it's an unfair suspension, right,
for something incredibly stupid. I've been talking to support
for. Okay, so the idea that people should be able to mass report
me from their multiple huge audience is stupid and goes against
absolutely everything Destiny has ever said for a start. Or these
people do it. Um, a really great example of this was uh Kelly
um who I think is permanently banned on Discord right now and
if you see her account anywhere you can report it and it will
be rebanned. Um, Kelly was constantly bringing up stuff about
my girlfriend. It's not like really a public figure at all. Just
a quick thing. Remember when he was so pro like like sorry so
against reporting that when I was asking for something to be
removed from just Discord so I didn't have to report it he shhat
on me for like an hour. Well that's true. How dare you report
things in Jtock server. Kelly that's crazy. The things that got
me banned were messages reported in your server. Just as a reference.
Do you want to say what they were? Cuz I think it helps. Yes.
me talking about being harassed relating to my underage pictures
being spammed in your Discord. That was the message that got
me banned. Yeah. To post basically like revenge whatever or trying
to basically dox her, although she'll say it didn't count as
doxing. So Destiny is arguing that apparently posting um his
girlfriend's public like like literally her job her her job is
to be a public influencer, right? like she is a cam girl, which
I don't need to throw judgment behind. Um, but that's been broadly
known for a long time. Apparently, Kelly posting that was was
doxing her according to Destiny. And then Destiny apparently
I did somebody post her in the server and it had to be removed
or something. I don't even know.
I don't know what he's talking about here. It that's just lies.
I've never posted anything directing to I don't even know what
her docs is or if it what like I've never linked to anything
like that and I've never posted any pictures of her either. Just
talked about her. Yeah, I
how would I have her revenge? What does that mean? She was a
cam girl. All of the stuff that we see paid for content. This
is this is his argument is that posting the publicly paid for
paid for content of somebody is revengeful. So objectively by
Destiny standard, he's posted revenge of Kelly Jean in his DGG
chat. Yes, there is also that. He's the one who did that. He's
like telling on himself. He was the one like posting my Only
Fans content. The real Dr. He was posting Kelly's Only Fans content
in his DG chat. Can I see it? Proof. Obviously, I can't pull
it up on stream, but I'm just saying that like you posted it
with revenge in your heart. Yeah, that's not how that works.
That doesn't make it revenge. But I also didn't post any pictures
of her at all. That's just a lie. I did not know that. That's
pretty bad. Yeah, I thought he was linking that. He linked that
He linked something from her. I I actually don't remember what
it was, but it's something from Kelly's Only Fans, like her paid
only fans content. He was linking that in his [__]
So, I don't know why he's a weirdo. That wouldn't be Wouldn't
that be equal culpability of posting like publicly posted but
behind a payw wall content in a hanger? Oh, yeah. It was like
video. It was video. He posted a video as well. Um, apparently
he posted a video as well. Yeah. Yeah. Which is fine. He just
found it on Google. It's like stuff gets leaked, right? It wasn't
anything like But like the point is exactly what he did. I didn't
post anything.
Well, that's what he's accusing you of is posting basically that
apparently. But I don't know if he's maybe. So in his mind, he
has like warped everything Kelly or I or Aquuman has done with
what Kiwi Farms has done. I think possibly. Yeah. I think like
I I don't know. He just like kind of makes up things over and
over. Although like I don't know. Maybe maybe some link got posted
somewhere. I have no idea. But it would have been removed. It
would have been against the rules, right?
So like I don't know if this happens, but it's just it's broadly
totally against any rules around my [__]
When he did that, I didn't make a big deal of it being revenge
either. It's just bizarre. It's like, yeah, if you post stuff
that you found on Google that is from Omi fans, it's kind of
like whatever. It's like I haven't posted her cam girl stuff,
but if I had, it wouldn't be revenge. That would be advertising,
which is the joke I made when he did it. It's like, thanks for
the free advertising, I guess.
Oh, sure. I'm just saying that like pen the person who links
your fail docs. He did not actually because it was Destiny himself.
Same for Queens. I just like I don't even apparently people here
didn't even know this happened. Yeah, I he's just like w I guess
maybe counterpoints knows it happened so I don't know why he
doesn't bring it up more like revenge of her or trying to basically
dox her although she'll say it didn't count as doxing she was
just linking separate accounts online and the reason
apparently doxing is linking like a chatterbait account or something.
I'm not sure how in the world that could possibly be the case
but I didn't even do that. Oh well, yeah. I don't know what he's
talking about. I linked to any of her stuff. I have no clue.
I hope Counterpoints asks So I would hope Counterpoints would
say, "Could you send me like evidence of her doing this?" Why
Kelly was doing that explicitly and she said it was she needs
to publicly disavow Steven and make statements like why? This
weird. So this pattern Kelly was just talking she was making
gross statements about Destiny's girlfriend, but like I don't
know if any of the things he just said happened happened. I would
love to see proof of those things. I didn't say anything that
wasn't true and he said worse about me and she has now too, so
it's fine. Uh, it could still be harassment to tell an anti-Fan
community his girlfriend. Well, what anti-fan community? One,
uh, all of those things were known months ago before anyone who
was doing anything before any of this was known about Destiny.
All of his uh, his girlfriend's like public influencer stuff
was known by all of these communities.
It's not about like even if you said the name, it wouldn't be
where they learned it from or anything close to that. Don't worry,
counterpoint shook his head in disapproval when he said the last
thing about you. I'm positive he's about to press Destiny. I'll
trying to isolate a person. He thinks that it's just cuz I mentioned
her cam name, but all of her links are linked publicly on her
profiles. Or they were until afterwards when she deleted them
all, but like it was all publicly linked on all of her like social
medias and stuff. Okay. Well, then I Yeah, I really don't understand
why she would be I don't know. I don't know how he would call
that doxing or anything close to doxing. That's uh pretty insane.
Much as possible. Yeah, but he also said, sorry, he also said
like she's not a public person. I'm sorry. You can't be a non-public
person and have an only fans and my free cams. That's not how
that's that doesn't make sense. You can say she's not like um
what's a public figure and a public person are different, right?
Maybe. Well, her but you can't be a private person and a cam
girl and I would say that doesn't make sense. I would say well
not a public person at all. Also like her face is a part of her
content. If if her face was like hidden, you were like identifying
her as like by her face somehow. Maybe. Uh yeah, maybe. Maybe
in that instance that would be a rare one. Maybe. Yeah. Yeah.
So, for a lot of people who don't respond to it, like for instance,
eventually they leave alone or like for me like they don't do
much for me because they know I don't give a [__]
right? Um, but then they start talking. Well, hold on. You don't
have to listen to Kelly's defense. He's just lying. He's just
like openly lying. Kelly doesn't like this person, but he's just
lying about the things that have happened like over and over
and over again. Kelly's defense is fine in this case. Like, hey,
uh, I didn't I might have talked about like her username, but
her username was like on her Twitter. She had it on her like
uh what do you call it? her like link triers and like all these
links were collected together. I didn't do that. She did that
bugging people around me. So, um I hate to give this whatever
right now. We also did like a what was it? Boax's we all decided
to sit around and discuss for a while but me talking about hemorrhoids
that's bad. I guess only person that seems to be engaging criticism
and I don't know why she does it or maybe she'll eventually is
is Kyla. And now you can see that all of these communities and
I'm sure you've seen it if you're in spiced forever. Now they're
all like hyper obsessed with Kyla and donating to her. You're
right. Actually, before these leaks, I don't think Spicy Chat
ever talked about Kyla or posted content about Kyla. I don't
think anybody who disliked Destiny had any negative comments
about Kyla ever before this. Wow, this guy is really intelligent.
Oh my god. Can we find anything anybody around Destiny or Destiny
Antifan community had ever said about Kylo before this or Oh
my goodness. Wow.
Wow. He just said that with a straight face. And by the way,
Conor, if Connor doesn't go, "Oh, that's insane." Um, like obviously
a bunch of these people have hated Kylo for a long time. If he
doesn't say something like that, I'd be very shocked. And watching
her stuff and harassing her because she's responding to it. Uh,
yeah, that would be doxing. As a mach I mean, probably I would
consider that doxing if it was years ago. But if it was like
two weeks ago and the accounts were linked and it's not somebody's
full name, I don't think that's possible.
I don't think anyone from this community has really harassed
Kyla. Like Royal did send a few donos that are a bit weird, but
technically weren't you giving her money? It kind of evens out
a bit. But also I hope you I totally I totally disavow going
to somebody's [__] to hate watch them and like send
donos. Like I totally disavow that. Ry does that. I can't like
I can't control him. I've just told him like that's [__]
weird. I don't The money evens it out a bit, right? Especially
with dono filters, you can kind of filter some of the words that
are said so it's not going to be like super bad. I don't know.
I know some weird stuff, but the idea that Kylo's only getting
Oh, I know what he's doing. Hold on. What he's doing is he's
trying to justify he's trying to justify never ever engaging
with this criticism because it's actually dangerous to engage
with this criticism, right? That's what he's trying to say here.
He's trying to build an environment where he can actually a priori
like knock out all criticism. It's like oh actually if I if I
engage with this or respond it's actually no that's actually
exactly why you would get harassed is because you responded at
all actually just not responding is the only thing you can do.
That's that's what he's trying to say. But it's like dude with
those people had problem sorry just real quick. People had problems
with Kylo's statements for months and years now. The whistleblower
thing gets brought up all the time. We can go watch the cherry
video on Kyla. Yes, this is all this is all insane. Like I I
don't understand why the he's sitting here trying to say, "Oh,
the only thing that uh the only reason people are going after
Kyla, that's because she's um she's engaging with the criticism."
Like, okay, so firstly, suggesting that sending someone a pizza
to someone's house is similar to sending like rage baked donos
is stupid because obviously knowing somebody's address is inherently
scary, even if you did actually preemptively pay for the pizza,
which nearly nobody does. Okay, that's scary because that's someone
saying, "I know your address," and they're being threatening.
Yeah. Whereas sending a ragebait dono, depending on if it like
breaches harassment or not, I don't know how demented Ri's dono
was, so I don't want to defend it necessarily. I just know he
was someone who did send one. But they're not in the same league
of like bad.
Obviously, I think when you're a streamer, you kind of do want
the occasional rage bait dono as long as they're not like I,
you know, like actual harassment. wouldn't I really wouldn't
justify just say like I disavow personally but I mean if you're
going to Well, I'm talking as a streamer who was a streamer and
you're a streamer. Do you not like rage bait donuts? I mean I
don't think it's even a rage bait donut. It's like hey you're
like talking about how Andrew Tate should be cancelled but also
like Destiny shouldn't be cancelled. That seems like confusing
to me. Like why should Andrew Tate be canceled but Desty shouldn't?
Like like why is
canc but like you're talking about canceling Andrew Tate right
now. Now I will say unequivocally Andrew Tate's conduct worse
than destinies obviously right but the idea that people are always
redeemable that's something Eerite keeps driving home and it's
like why are you talking about redemption for somebody who has
not you know reversed or made any amends for their conduct whatsoever
right
why are you being like this I don't get it the first thing I
said was we shouldn't be harassing anyone or we already don't
direct people to harass anyone and when would I when have I ever
said go harass Eerodite in my knife like you're being very strange
today. I don't get it explicitly and she said it was she needs
to publicly disavow Steven and make like why is this no excuse?
So this pattern of trying to isolate a person as much as possible.
Oh, so for a lot of people who don't respond to it uh like Dan
for instance eventually they leave him alone or like me like
don't do much for me. No. Fat Destiny donated
$6.54. Fat Destiny here. I love rage bait donos as much as I
love food and violating consent. Okay. Thank you, Fat Destiny.
Thank you very much for the donation. I appreciate it. Guys,
don't forget if you like the content, go ahead and throw me a
sub on kick. Donate through either of the links. Exclamation
boy donate in the chat. Kickbot link is is uh pinned at the top
of the chat here. So, I know I don't give a [__]
right? Um but then they start targeting people around me. So,
um, I hate to give error power to this or whatever, but right
now the only person that seems to be engaging with that criticism,
and I don't know why she does it, or maybe she'll eventually
is is Kyla. And now you can see that all of these communities,
and I'm sure you've seen it if you're in [__] only
once she gave air or or oxygen to the criticism at all, then
that's when they started harassing her. That's when they started
now. They're all like hyper obsessed with Kyla and donating to
her and watching her stuff and harassing her because she's responding
to it. So that no I mean I I'll say when the when the drama was
you know white hot and uh orbiters were willing to either comment
or not comment uh the only thing that would be acceptable to
a certain amount of people was uh you know JTO uses the term
eat
yeah queen has um I mean it's literally funny it's literally
funny but I didn't I didn't tell I I don't know what Connor's
doing here this is kind of Hold on let me copy this URL. Uh,
he's ins he's saying I insisted on saying e. When did I insist
on other people using e? I just said e is not bad. You can get
mad about it, but it is not bad. I've never said you have to
call him an e or I'll kick you out of here. Never said that.
What the [__] is he talking about? Why? Why are you
just making this up? Okay. Used the term predator. Uh some some
people have said offense registry and uh if if you have like
I think if you record conversations uh without people's consent
repeatedly that's something that should be notified. Your future
partner should be notified of that. That's the argument. That's
always been the argument. Connor has just literally never once
engaged with that argument in good faith. It's the first time
he got raped by Queman and Lav. He's been raped on that argument
every time since. It's an obvious position to have and he just
copes about well actually sometimes sex offenders get killed.
It's like, okay. It's like, I don't even need to call it a secret.
I just say probably your future partners deserve to know about
this. Boom. That's it. Yeah. I think people are seeing in real
time how unseriously the majority of people take like sex crimes
in general and how few of them end up being prosecuted to any
extent. So, it's like this is probably going to end up like quite
depressing by the end of it. like a sober evaluation like hey
uh this is up you know Stephen I mean at this point Destiny's
gone to insane extents with the other stuff. So I mean the whole
the death threats and the doxing I would imagine can be sent
around to um like literally people who are covering your material
who you can't produce any evidence of the the conduct that you're
saying justifies it. Um you've you've tried to dox them. You've
asked for their doc information and you've called for their death.
You've said I really want people to go kill these guys. Like
I don't know what what more needs to be like that already on
its own should be reputationally reputational poison for the
Democratic party. Could you imagine if Assan did this? Holy the
internet would explode. Could you imagine if Assan did this?
If he was like actually yeah I do hope those people die. Yeah,
I do want somebody to go kill them. And then every time people
are like hey do you mind like taking that back and saying you
don't want that? He's like no here's all the reasons why it's
a good thing. Here's all the reasons why I do still have those.
Right. Could you imagine if Assan did this? Dude, that it would
never end. It would never end. Been [__] up XYZ as
far as I can tell. However, I think that you uh Hassan didn't
do that and you guys are actually morons for thinking that. But
it's fine. The Rick the Rick Scott comment is not even remotely
comparable. Prison just tipped. I refuse to sit here while people
compare me to a DDG or I respect all women and all the cases
on me are fraudulent. W Kelly bought Kingler. The hypothetical
is if you non-conensually record interactions and you've shown
a pattern of doing it and you send those around to other people,
should you have to warn future partners that you are a risk to
their like privacy? The answer should be yes. Now, if you want
to argue about other things, that's the hypothetical that Connor
wouldn't engage with. It's very easy to engage with. The answer
is just yes. And if you don't want to engage with the fact that
there's already proof of that on the internet, that's fine with
me. you guys are being crazy. Yeah. Potentially also just to
be clear that is allegedly that is what Connor is saying and
I am not uh sure that Yeah. allegedly. Yeah. Go ahead. Yeah.
Yeah. But the but but the point is from you know we we have information
that we're all evaluating. We're all making judgment calls off
of what's publicly. If you're if you're one of the people who's
like, "No, when Destiny said that he totally got permission and
actually the guy consented to the recording, but just didn't
want to risk the camera being out. So that's why the audio is
totally scuffed by remaining in the pocket and they couldn't
find any other way to cover it so that the audio wouldn't be
totally and Destiny didn't definitely point out that the audio
was [__] right? And he apologized for the audio being.
So he didn't want the audio to be [__] but he recorded
from his pocket. But actually, he got consent, but he can't produce
that consent in any meaningful way. He didn't keep any records
of it. He just like he and he didn't do it even though he like
walks up with the phone in his pocket. You can see he hasn't
met the guy. You hear that he hasn't met the guy yet and he still
goes and does all of this, right? You don't hear him ask for
consent in the moment and you can't post text logs. There's nothing.
There's nothing. All of these things that all makes sense to
me. If you're like that, then um hey,
I've wish I had cultlike followers like that. I wish I had people
who I could just say things, say the most insane things, and
then they'd be like, "Oh my god, yeah, we won, guys. We won."
Oh, it's awesome. I wish. Would you really? Wouldn't you just
like get depressed and cry yourself? No. Lose your beard and
become sad and pathetic. I I but I don't I don't like uh predate
on women at all. So, I don't um I don't have to worry about it.
I just have cultic following. But without the the predation is
fine available. And so unless uh unless people are willing to
condemn you in the harshest terms possible, that is insufficient
for the crusade that is going after your digital head. I've literally
always said if you if you're somebody who's waiting, just don't
denigrate the victims, right? Just don't go and say like I don't
believe these people. These people are lying or something, right?
I've said that to multiple people and then people want to argue
my assertions about Destiny. I'll argue with those people too.
I don't need anybody to come out and say like if people just
want to shut the [__] up about this. I don't go find
people who haven't spoken and I'm like, "Oh, you brutal piece
of shit." I don't do that. Also, for the uh person that said,
"Why is Kelly wearing this hat?" It's a Sherlock Holmes hat.
And what do you
Reban Ruben donated $3. I wish you had people like that, too.
Thank you. So, I appreciate that. I appreciate you. Thank you,
Reuben. Reuben, I opened OBS and I didn't check how loud it was,
so I just got that dono at like 100 massive decibels of something.
I'm deaf now. But they said, "Why am I not wearing an autism
helmet?" I'm like, "You don't think Sherlock Holmes is as autistic
as?" I think you are right. Is it Sherlock Holmes smart? Sorry.
You think like smart and autistic or mutually exclusive? Oh dear.
Are you there just Hello. Yeah, but it's not to be clear also,
it's not even really about condemnation. It's always about isolation
and se separating. That's the goal. The goal is they want to
punish you kind of. They want to punish you. No. No. I think
informing is mostly what it is. Punishment implies like behavior
change or something. These people just don't want me to be on
the internet anymore. They want to get rid of they want to destroy
my stuff online. They want to destroy my destroy me basically.
So the goal is always the person hasn't been harsh enough. And
by harsh they mean totally separate. Yo, some sauce. Think of
the five gifted. Let's go. I got it. I got one. nice destroy
me basically. So the goal is always if a person hasn't been harsh
enough and by harsh they mean totally separated then that person
will continue to be targeted over and over and over again until
that person has has broken it off and people like just no uh
no actually I think the reason Kyla gets gone after is because
she makes moral claims that are totally inconsistent, right?
Like she's called Mr. Girl evil. She's gone and called Mr. Girl
evil. She had moral qualms with Chud logic over something that
is insanely lower grade compared to these things, right? and
she had moral judgment for them. And as soon as she had to change
her morals completely to support Destiny, she did. So that's
why people get annoyed, right? That's why that's that's it. I'm
sorry. Like we can we can cope about oh it's like people just
want Destiny isolated. No, it's Eerite claims she had like this
moral these moral views on the world, right? And I think probably
like when Destiny is, you know, calling for the death of people,
I think probably it's then like, "Oh, are you still hanging out
with this guy?" She's like, "Well, everyone can be redeemed."
It's like, "Okay, I don't know." Like you're ready, you're ready
to cut off Chud Logic from being on anything else. Do everything
in your power over what? Over what? And now you're like, "No,
I have to I have to stick by Destiny." And it's usually comes
out that it's because he was nice to me. That's usually what
it is. Mystical and Queenman have played into that. So if you're
going to like engage in that type of destructive behavior, then
I I yeah, I have no concern for you. And then they'll play stupid
about it, right? They're like, "Whoa, we've never posted this
thing or whatever, but they know what's happen.
We've never posted this thing. What does that even mean?" Kelly,
respond in chat, please. If you're responding to a chat. No,
I'm responding to you.
You just said, "Oh, it's because she's been nice to me." Doesn't
everyone have somewhat of a bias where they tend to have preferential
treatment to people that have been nice to them? Yep. But most
people don't excuse like um like a lot of the non-consensual
recording stuff. They don't excuse it on that basis. And then
probably just the whole like he can be redeemed, but he's continued
to hurt people. Like continue to stand while he is again the
metaphor is while he's still stabbing people. You're standing
there being like, "He can be redeemed." Like, he literally is
walking over to a st to a victim. He's about to stab and and
Erid's like, "He can be redeemed. I don't want to I don't want
to. He's been really nice to me. He can be redeemed." And then
he stabs the person. She's like, "What? It's bad. That was him
stabbing that person. That was bad. What do you want me to say?"
It's a little transparent. How about if you know that the person's
not going to be redeemed, but they personally help you, so you
want to keep them around. Yeah. Right. Yeah. So, I have no concern
for those.
Where's the redemption thing? Where is it at all analogous? Hold
on. I just want to point out that Kelly is W farming again. No,
because I'm not saying what I'm talking about. Totally W farming.
Oh, it's very talking to you. I I wouldn't be surprised if there
was cross-pollination between
uh psycho psycho drama farmers and non-sychotic drama farmers.
Sure. Well, that's one issue is again like I said, there are
legitimate criticisms of course you can make of my behavior.
Uh there are condemnations that you can make. There are obviously
I've committed mistakes or done bad things or wrong things. Like
this is all for sure true. But the um but the there are so many
communities that are poised to just weaponize it in the most
extreme way possible. And then if you don't, you end up being
targeted by these communities. Yeah.
So here here's a common talking point that I've heard uh brought
up that I'm sure that if I if I don't bring it up, then there
there's going to be people who like cry blood. Uh some I just
missed I I was looking at something else DMs or something. I'll
have to go back. I'll have to relisten. Willing to either comment
or not comment. Uh the only thing that would be acceptable to
a certain the high level as far as I can tell. However, I think
that you guys are being crazy.
Just to be clear, that is allegedly that what you're digital
person has has broken it off and people log like concern. I wouldn't
be surprised if there was a crosspollination between
uh sorry it's right I have to sorry I keep clicking backwards
and this is like such a long body. concern for you and then they'll
play stupid about it, right? They're like, "Oh, we've never posted
this thing or whatever, but they know what's happening. We're
not Everybody knows, right?" Yeah. So, I have no concern for
those. I wouldn't I wouldn't be surprised if there was cross-pollination
between
uh psycho psycho drama farmers and non-sychotic drama farmers.
Sure. Well, that's one issue is again like I said, there are
legitimate criticisms of course you can make of my behavior.
Uh there are condemnations that you can make. There are obviously
I've committed mistakes or done bad things or run things like
this is all for sure true but the um but the there are so many
communities that are poised to just weaponize it in the most
extreme way possible and then if you don't you end up being targeted
by these
where hold on aren't there a whole bunch of people who's been
targeted who's been like targeted at all
yeah there are no calls to action anywhere ever like we we just
cover some of the airday content and I like stopped covering
I was literally like Okay, she's just saying the same thing.
Like unless I get reference, I I've like not been bringing up
Aridite at all. She specifically talked about me in a bunch of
her first streams and then there's a bunch of cope. Like I don't
know. I don't know what to do. Like am I supposed to not am I
supposed to not cover people talking about me? Apparently covering
people who talk about you means you're obsessed. Okay, I guess.
Yeah. So here here's a common talking point that I've heard uh
brought up. Although actually, hold on. with the aerodyite stuff.
I just again when she had like the stupid copes around Destiny,
that's what I was covering. But like as soon as she started doing
we watched a little bit of like one of her red pill things and
it was like broadly not very entertaining. Like it's not quite
it's not quite the same. It doesn't hit the same. So I don't
know whatever he's projecting again. Start pointing it out. He's
repeatedly attributing his actions to you. Oh, true. Yeah. No,
there is projection here. Um there is isolation. Uh absolutely.
He goes he reports people. Supreme makes a comment in my Discord.
Destiny leaks all of this about Supreme. He leaks like apparently
that Pixie and Supreme had a relationship. I would that would
actually be right there when he's talking about isolation. I
guess we should go back. Let me go separating. That's isolation
and separation. We should pause and he makes up a completely
malicious lie about Supreme here. Oh, I didn't do the previous
one, but here we'll go.
completely malicious lie about Supreme to prevent him from coming
on stream or commenting further or participating in my community.
Um, he's done the same thing to when Lonerbox was participating
in my community or commenting on this stuff. He went off and
maliciously lied about Lonerbox, right? He's he's done it about
everybody. people who broadly cover his stuff, even people who
aren't insane, um they will get maliciously lied about over and
over and over again until they stop and then they stop and then
part though. That's true. I am actually a sea monster. That wasn't
a lie. I'm like a kraken. I am. Oh, that's Yeah, that's that
is a good point that it's projection that this is his goal is
to isolate us, right? And it's I mean, broadly it's working because
he's got a way bigger platform. So people go after these people,
people will unsub from these people and they'll go, "Oh, actually
covering this stuff is really bad. I guess I'll move on to something
else in context here." It's it's not even remotely the same.
Oh, hold on. As a result, this is uh just desserts or karma.
Uh he threatened to post more stuff about me and Zoe explicitly
just for being in your Discord uh which Kelly exists in and to
leave or get harassed. True. Yes. Yeah. He actually does this
stuff all the time. It's uh it's pretty crazy. that uh you're
hypocritical because of your interactions with Keles and your
interactions with Anna where you alluded to them having information
on these harassment websites. And so as a result again when Anna's
thread had like three pages on it, Destiny was like, "You guys
need to go to this brand new Kiwi Farms page, Anna's Kiwi Farms
thread. Go there and talk about Anna all you like, right? Go
to Kiwi Farms Anna's Kiwi Farms thread." He he did objectively
direct his audience there. Yes, this is uh just desserts or karma
coming back your way. So if he only sorry if he only thinks that
Kiwi Farms is a harassment platform, then why did he have null
on his stream and why did he make an account and engage on this
website? You must surely think that there is at least a bit more
to it than that simply.
Right? So, it's either he's just straight up lying or he he's
trying to I guess discredit everyone that's ever posted there
or is associated with there at all. It's just I don't know. Yeah.
I he helped fund KF at one point. Also, just really quickly,
apparently the guy who's prolifically doxed uh people around
Destiny and Destiny or whatever, apparently that guy found the
found the site because he was a Destiny fan and he was directed
there by Anavar or to to the Anavar thread apparently. That's
but I have no idea. So, that's that's what I've heard. That's
what's being said in my chat. I don't know if that's true, but
um I just want to point out that Connor said real quick, I'm
going to point out that Connor says and this is like just desserts
for you now. Nobody said that Destiny deserves to get doxed.
They're saying that Destiny saying that, "Oh, I'm because because
of Kiwi Farms doing something, I'm going to blame all these other
people and start doing the things that I think Kiwi Farms is
worse for, doxing and doing death threats and stuff." That's
that's his argument is like, "Oh, because these people are like
Kiwi Farms, which is the worst thing in the world. I'm going
to go after them." And it's like, bro, you didn't think it was
the worst thing in the world when you were using it to intimidate
people. You still use it. You this whole thing as we've shown
in logs and you've literally used it repeatedly to try to harass
people this entire time before any of the stuff was happening
around your girlfriend, right? You were doing this. This was
He is a monster of his own creating. Exactly. That's very true.
Well, it's it's mostly that like you don't actually think this
is bad or you think you've been you've tried to intimidate people
and be evil yourself, right? But like how c how the could you
possibly say that now all of these other people are responsible
when you don't there's no direct link between them you have a
direct link you have pushed people there intentionally right
but I don't but he has gone after me to do the things the worst
things he thinks Kiwi Farms does he's tried to go after me with
those same tactics so I don't know on both sides he's asked on
both sides he's totally wrong but I've never said oh people around
him deserve to get docked because he's used Kiwi Farms or supported
Kiwi Farms no I broadly disavow that go ahead Kelly. Uh, no,
I agree with that. It's fine. Um, yeah, it's uh it's either a
monster of his own creating or he doesn't really believe anything
he's saying and it's hard to know which because he just lies
a lot. So, who knows? It would be funny if like in 2 years time
Kiwi Farms becomes like um what's the word? Convenient for him
again and then he just uses them. Yeah, I don't know. Yeah, I
wouldn't be surprised.
The overlap of unhinged drama farmers with not unhinged drama
farmers. Connor said this is Queman and you uh I don't know what
you mean here. I heard this from Jtock was specifically that
uh you're hypocritical because of your interactions with Cath.
Not that he deserves it. Sorry. Not that he deserves and your
interactions with uh just desserts or karma coming back your
way. No. So h how do you feel? No, that's not that's not it at
all. I that oh that's a a real butchering of my argument
about them saying that this is either hypocritical or it's karmic
balance. Yeah. I mean like you can say these things but these
these aren't real criticisms. Um like if you look at my engagement
with Anna. So some people like to bring this up um and say like
well Destiny's mad because people are linking to his uh Kiwi
farms. Destiny's mad about that. But he linked what? No.
No, I don't because I don't do that. That's not That's not what
I do. It's literally banned from my server. You can't do that,
dude. And there's Kiwi Farms, right? Well, if you look at the
two differences in context here, it's it's not even remotely
the same. So, like for instance, for the Anna stuff, like I legitimately
was trying to it goes back and forth, but I think at this point
in time, I didn't want anything in my community. I didn't want
anybody talking about her because anytime she would see a statement
that she would perceive about her as being incorrect. Okay. So,
why didn't you just ban all mentions and just say, "Stop talking
about her." Like, what? Why did you have to direct Why?
Please, Connor. Connor, please don't just let him say that. Connor,
you can't just let him get away with that. Why is I broadly not
wanted to talk to Destiny. Um, Destiny's just good at moving
perception. I just don't see any reason. I can just analyze this
after the fact. Like, I I would rather talk. He's so lazy. They're
not even good lies. They're just very bad lies. He just doesn't
put any effort in anymore. It feels disappointing. I don't know.
They're not. I want to see I I saw the logs. There are logs from
Anna somewhere where she's like upset about getting docks on
Kiwi Farms. Like she's upset about him directing people towards
her docks. And I I want to say, am I am I incorrect? Is it the
Mr. Girl report? Maybe. What was his response to that? Cuz I
could have sworn his response to that was like, "Stop talking
about me then. You're doing this to I thought it was something
like you're doing this to yourself." Am I crazy? Wait, while
I'm while I'm looking this up, talk for a second. Kelly, don't
forget to donate, guys. Don't forget to donate and sub. Okay,
talk for a second about what? Just like your lies, Kelly Pomero.
Sorry. What does that mean? You think I've told egregious lies
like Destiny has been lately? Give me one. I'd love to know.
Medical update. No, you don't want that. You're just trying to
bait me into saying something to make everyone angry. Okay. Please
don't. I'll give you a hundred. Wait, what for? How? How? What
do I have to do to make just a call $100? Do I have to I don't
want to dance.
give you 100. Ellie is a connoisseur of lies. She would know.
Wait, how does that relate to $100?
I don't know. But I found I found this section here. I I can
probably find the actual screenshots. I think I've seen it. I'm
poor. Boo.
So, uh, he says go over to you chatter. You can actually go to
Kiwi Farms and you can go post all you want, read all you want,
make accounts there. People put a lot of effort into categorizing
and archiving everything. There you go. Okay, so that's his characterization
of Kiwi Farms. If you're obsessed with Anna, you go there where
I I know all of her most obsessed skitsos would be. You go there,
chatter. That's what he says. Anna's Kiwi Farms thread had been
created two weeks earlier and had averaged 1.4 posts per day.
The day Destiny single boosted the thread, there were 35 posts
followed by another 99 that week. Okay, so he clearly did that.
And his full name and city were doxed the day Destiny announced
the thread with one user saying, "Kimmy just lied on stream saying
her doc is fake and the information is not true." All right,
challenge accepted. Stalker. The user posted Anna's family photos
and screenshots from her family social media to prove that she
has successfully been doxed. Anna DM'd Destiny, "What the [__]
is wrong with you? You just had a that Kiwi Farms thread about
me, dude. You are horrible." Destiny said, "I have a media blackout
related to your stuff and I wanted everyone to get it out before
we were uh before people were talking about it incessantly over
the next two weeks as more and more people discovered it. You
are constantly talking about me on your stream, so I think it's
fair for me to bring it up." And you went as far to say I was
abusive the last time you mentioned me. It's literally I you
deserve this because you said I was abusive. That's literally
what it is. Hey, you deserve this, [__] And now he's
like, "Oh, the context is different." Uh, because you threatened
to leak my dudes. You sociopath. You literally ruined my life.
You just doxed me on your stream. [__] you. You put
me in danger. And his response, the classic, you're doing it
to yourself and you're going to keep doing it to yourself. Like,
how does anybody support this guy? He's actually the biggest
piece of in the world. And now, now he's sitting here with Connor.
Okay. Holy. Now he's sitting here with Connor and he's like,
"Oh, uh, I hope Connor's like willing to go and say something
like, "Hey, wait, what was the context of it again? You just
said the context was I didn't want people talking about her anymore.
I was actually trying to help." Dude, it's not the same remotely
the same. So, like for instance, for the Anna stuff, like I legitimately
was trying to it goes back and forth, but I think at this point
in time, I didn't want anything in my community. I didn't want
anybody talking about her because anytime she would see a statement
that she would perceive about her as being incorrect, she would
feel the need to start streaming and going off and off on it
and it would just it created this horrible cycle. And I think
I said because what was happening was clarify
I feel like is important. Anna was streaming to maybe like a
hundred people. Anything she said on any of Yes. Anything that
she said on her stream was irrelevant and could have been ignored
by him. Absolutely anything. Nobody would have care. I also but
also he can respond to it if he wants, right? He can respond
to it if he wants. He can say where the lies are. Just address
what he's she's saying. The problem was he had a very messy relationship
with her. There probably were abusive things going on when when
she's like, "Hey, you called me a stalker and that's crazy."
And he's like, "Oh, don't worry about that now. Just let me rub
your feet your feet and thighs." Like, that is weird. And those
are actually like very poor behaviors. He did threaten to leak
her nudes because she she she talked about him being abusive
or something, right? Like these are abusive behaviors. They are
bad behaviors. Yeah, that's why he went this aggressive.
I I just wanted to point out like a pattern of him like he wants
to control things, right? So that's why he freaks out when Anna
makes a statement on an irrelevant little stream no one's really
going to care or watch, right? He has to blow it up in front
of his 10,000 viewer audience. It's like, why? It's unnecessary.
And it's just because you don't want you want to control the
narrative about you, right? There's no other reason for it because
otherwise you'd look at it logically and be like, "Okay, this
literally doesn't matter." But he wants to like stomp these people
out. He wants to intimidate them. He wants to crush them. Yeah.
I I like this this was him and I don't even understand remotely
how I I don't understand how you could remotely try to present
this as like as oh I was just trying to get her I just didn't
want people to talk about her in my community that's all and
it's like then you you contra you you flip that with uh but you
you've been talking about me you said I was abusive and uh this
is all your fault you ruin she's like you ruined my life and
dox me like you you're doing it to yourself you're doing it to
yourself my god Yes, it's exactly what Zan Hill just said. Just
to go ironically, he was accusing her of obsessing over the narrative
and correcting the record. Meanwhile, he's doing exactly the
same thing. Yes. It's a reputation rehab that he used to scream
all of the time.
This is the big projection he does. Yes. Biggest perpetuator
of that. Yes. Yeah. This is the biggest projection he does, which
is uh guys, they have to go fix their reputation. They have to
make sure everything's right. And he's the person who has to
do it most. He's the reason that he Sorry. That's the reason
he chased Lav into that call at 4:00 a.m. on the Tom Fury stream
with Tom Fury and Stardust and or what? Tom Fury and and Catnip.
Katniss. Cat, I think. Katniss. Catnip. No, Cassie. Catnip. That's
the one. Yeah. Right. He chased her into that call at 4 a.m.
while his in-laws were in town. He had to go out to his car on
his phone to talk to her. Connor points put out the Mr. Girl
Report commentary one month ago. He's no excuse for forgetting.
Actually, that's another good point. Conor Connor just went and
read the Mr. girl report a month ago and he totally forgot about
this section of the Mr. girl report where Destiny is clearly
not saying it's clearly not just oh I just wanted people not
to talk about her anymore. He clearly is maliciously or I would
say at least there's some part in his head where he's like it's
fine you said I was abusive. It's fine that I mentioned this
right and then he tells her she's doing it to herself. It's literally
hey if you stop talking about me this wouldn't have happened.
Oh sure got the link to because he knows they are more easy to
abuse. another mentally ill woman that Destiny had a long conflict
with to go. Also, heads up, this is my only non-media blackout
time. Okay, this is my only non- media black time over me like
this. Okay, somebody on Kiwi Farms has made a thread of Anna.
So, if you are obsessed with Anna and you want to talk about
her all the time, you chatter, you can actually go to Kiwi Farms
and you can go and post all you want. Re guys, he just knew that
her docs was coming out. He knew that she'd been doxed and he
just didn't want people talking about her docs more in his community.
That's why he sent them all to Kiwi Farms where her docs would
definitely get posted. Guys, he was just trying to help her.
He was just trying to be helpful. Oh my god. What do you mean
he wasn't just trying to be helpful? Read all you want. Go there,
post about it, talk about it. People put a lot of effort into
categorizing and archiving everything. There you go. Okay. And
in the thread about Anna that Destiny encouraged his fans to
go message they doxed Anna. And it was later revealed that at
this time Destiny was secretly in an ongoing relationship with
Anna. Oh wait wait wait wait hold on there's no way. Hold on.
That's a different Hold on. There was an ongoing relationship
but I don't know if it was timelinewise the day of the Kiwi Farms
leak. Two days prior. I So May 20. Oh no, it is. Oh no, it is.
It is. Worse.
Oh my god,
dude. This guy This guy's a scumbag. This guy is a real piece
of [__] It's amazing that you can like go through
these things and it's like actually looks so much worse. I'll
I'll note, by the way, Yogi appears to have disappeared from
chat. He does not want to defend this
apparently. Wow. I wouldn't want to defend this either. That
guy just took the off. Oh my goodness. I'd get the [__]
out, too. Holy [__] Just a a real piece of [__]
There's a Kiwi Farms thread that was posted and everybody kept
basically doing whatical servers doing. They would link it in
my chat like, "Oh my god, did you see that? Did you see that?"
And I think I said something on stream to
basically doing a lot of work there. Links to Kiwi Farms are
banned from my discord. That's like something you can't do. I
don't know. Basically is doing a lot of work. basically means
not actually happening at all. And I'm never I'm never going
on here and going like go to page X of Desi's thread to look
at like this thing that's obviously going to like put somebody
in trouble, right? I've never done anything close to that. That
is equivalently what he did. And also even if I did that in terms
of amplification, I have nowhere near the audience size and going
off and off on it and it would just it would create this horrible
cycle that was posted. I actually just want to comment on that
just to put it into perspective. This would be like if justical
freaked out that I don't know, Chris Bett lettuce said something
he didn't like about him with like his five viewers. That is
sort of like the comparative difference. It looks very stupid.
And then just told everyone in his Discord and audience to go
dox and harass Chris lettuce and go kill him. That would be the
similar sort of don't do that to Chris Lettuce. That's horrible.
He does give himself away a little bit here. Okay, he does give
himself away a little bit. Okay, so he didn't want people in
his community talking about it, right? He didn't want people
talking about Anavar. It's like he just he sees it as PE they
didn't want people talking about her at all. They didn't want
her people talking about how she was getting harassed. It's like
it's just narrative control. Um he like connects Anna to my discord.
It's like the same thing. That's why he is abusive to both. That's
why he is like trying to attack and destroy. What was happening
was was there was a Kiwi Farms thread that was posted and everybody
kept basically doing what Jical server is doing where they would
link it in my chat like, "Oh my god, did you see that? Did you
see that?" And I think I said something on stream to the Oh,
I see. Never mind. No. Um I would have just probably banned links
to it. He has literally like reax linking link banning in his
but I don't understand. There's no way that you He's basically
saying, "Okay, imagine the leaks happened and I just directed
people exactly to the page where the leaks were, right?" and
said, "Guys, don't talk about the leaks that are directly on
this page." That's what he did, right? Don't talk about Anna
and then linked to the exact place where within two clicks you
can find the most sensitive information about her, right? What
is reax? Regular expressions as in you can ban pattern, you can
pattern match for links. Yes. Uh, by the way, said the first
time, but go ahead. I mean not the only reason but the additional
reason why he's doing this is to also control what happens here
right so he's sort of reinforcing that we have to be better than
him in X Y and Zed ways and have to prove that fact as well whilst
he can just be an absolute schizophrenic doing the most evil
[__] without anyone holding him accountable at all.
So it's just like why would you speak when you know that everything
you have done is a hundred times worse. I don't where do you
get off? It's very effective. Listen, if you want to talk about
her, go to a caref and talk about her. Don't do it here. I don't
want to see this here. This isn't going to be talked about here.
Get out. Okay, that was my statement on it. They're trying to
pretend like that statement is the same as the 50 extra discords
and the room that uh you know just deal has where they explicitly
talk about all of my stuff on there over 50 rooms uh you know
just has where they explicitly talk about all of my stuff on
there. He's talking about like the looper chat that we had for
like 2 seconds and then we got rid of cuz it didn't work. Why
would he be talking about that? Why would he know about literally
nothing about Jesse ever got posted in that chat? It was just
people beamed about it over and over and over again and they're
linking to it and they're referencing it and talking about it
constantly. It's clearly not the same thing. Like if Jessica
or any of those side servers made the same statement about me
that I made about um Anna, I would be totally fine with that
if they were like, "Listen guys, we're not going to talk about
their personal [__] anymore. If you want to talk
about it or like their docs or whatever, if you want to talk
about it." Wait, that's actually what the purpose of that second
channel was. It was like, "Hey, if you want to go talk about
Destiny stuff, you should go here." That was like what I was
trying to do. I just nobody I thought it was I thought it was
like people bullying specific chatters and they were looping
so it was to go loop with the loopers. I don't think it was even
about Destiny. In any case, why is he It's like a false dichotomy.
You're you're already not allowed to link Destiny's Kiwi Farms
thread, right? You're literally not He's just saying I don't
want people to talk about the bad things I've done or the bad
things I do. It's like no you maybe you shouldn't have done the
bad things. I'm sorry. But it's not doesn't make it Kiwi Farms.
I'm sorry.
I think that this guy has gotten off relatively easy when it
comes to the the amount of shaming that he's received because
most people just don't want to deal with him. And so he's throwing
a tantrum at like the smallest amount of shaming that he's gotten
despite the fact that all of this doxing and stuff that was done
to him and people around him was done before all of this stuff
happened. It's like I don't know cry more like I don't know how
he gets out of the Anavar thing so easily here but then go to
K and talk about it. I'd be totally fine with that. But that's
clearly that's not they're dead. Yeah. Then what? Max Kelly fatty
cuz he's watching probably. Also Destiny and I haven't so like
there's no inappropriate there there's a relationship and they've
had sex before. Like the Anna thing is so beyond in like every
way. Max's criticism of that action is that you are a secret
manipulative genius
whose true motivation is no. is not to genius that toxic element
of your community out. It's to effectively harass Anna into silence.
So, how do you Wait, he literally says it. Conor,
you come on, dude. Dude, there's no way. There's no way. You
just take that on good faith. Really, bro? Oh my god. Hold on.
I need to write a quote for this.
uh, Mr. girl had to mindread you to see malevolence. And again,
maybe Connor would read this differently. Possibly he'd read
it differently, right? But when when you have this exchange where
she's like, "You this is soed up." And he's like, "Well, actually,
I want everyone to get it out before people were talking about
it incessantly over the next two weeks as more people discovered
it like the KF thread. I guess you're constantly talking about
me on your stream and I so I think it's fair for me to bring
it up. You went as far to say I was a good piece." He's literally
saying because you talk about me, I brought it up. because you
talk about me. I brought it up cuz you threatened to leak my
nudes. So she apparently he had just threatened to leak her nudes,
which doesn't even seem shocking to me. Okay, I don't know about
it this precisely. He doesn't say it. He doesn't say no. Right
now, this is a loop back and forth, but he does this insane escalation,
which is posting basically directing people towards a thread.
That's that's Doxter. I I don't know what he means by I push
people there before they're talking about it incessantly. Like
the KF thread or the docs. I actually don't know. Um it could
just be the KF thread, right? Why not just ban mentions of kiwi
farms in your sh? Okay. Destiny immediately threatened to cut
ties with her if she kept talking. Wow. Oh, this was laugh. Sorry,
this is a different thing. You're doing it to yourself. This
is the end of this one. But I just I don't know how. We're just
going to take his word for it despite there being logs from back
here. That's basically like stop talking about me. So, you acknowledge
that you've been sexing with Whoops. Whoops. For a year, I think.
Yeah, we've had on and off. Sure. In that such it was such an
insane moment there. That was crazy. Back to this. Yeah. So the
there's a fun game that's played and it's very frustrating, but
basically and I and I think I actually I um I let myself get
controlled by this like if I was somebody like Yogi just watching
how calmly he can lie about the circumstances of the Ana thing
here with like no there's no human emotion happening here. He
is he is just like calmly flat out lying despite there being
documentary evidence that he is incorrect here. Right? There's
that's it. Like he is he is objectively lying right now. He is
objectively misrepresenting what happened and he can just do
it so calmly, so effortlessly. Shouldn't that like concern people?
Wouldn't that be like I it it's so like it's lizardlike. It just
makes my skin crawl too much is that I'm basically unable to
defend myself in any way, size, shape, or form without it being
seen as some form of control or manipulation. And I think Wait,
how are you defend Wait, how? Hold on. Connor should be asking.
Wait, how are you defending yourself? I thought you were just
trying to like make sure that none of this stuff was talked about
anymore. How are you defending yourself here? You were just trying
to clean up your community. You didn't even You weren't even
defending yourself. You were just like, "Wait, where's the defense?"
Unless you're implying you did something to defend your like
where where's the defense there? It's just you saying I didn't
want to discuss to my community anymore. He's crying about how
defense of himself coming from himself is seen as manipulative
and bad when in the same conversation he just called for me to
get mass reported by his community. And that defense of all of
the other insane things that he said and just then further lying
about other people and other situations. It's just like, have
you considered not doing those things and maybe just talking
about the situation that happened instead of trying to attack
other people's characters and their safety? I don't. And the
guy talk about deplatforming for so often is apparently okay
with this now. I don't All he has to do is point out where people
are lying. Just watch like he was watching a ton of the content
before. Why isn't he watching the content pointing out where
people are lying? Why wouldn't you do that? He he will talk about
literally anything that isn't like in detail the wrongdoing that
he did. Like everything that he's speaking about is his complaints
with how other people are covering the insane things that he's
done. It's like if he tried just not being insane, then there
wouldn't be anything for us to talk about. But you keep escalating
things. Yeah. Well, this is his response is shouldn't I be able
to defend myself? And it's like, yes, but not by lying or like
maliciously escalating to a place other people aren't willing
to go and you know they're not willing to go. I'd say probably
those things. Endless calls to actions to do things to kill you
guys, to dox you guys, to report people. It's just like, yeah,
you're like everything that you preached against like months
ago. I don't I think yeah controlled by this too much is that
I'm basically unable to defend myself in any way, size, shape
or form without it being seen as some form of control or manipulation.
And I think I've actually been too soft on people in the past
or I've been too consiliatory because if I say anything, oh,
again from Connor here, it would just be, hey, um, so you're
escalating way past anything they've done or anything you could
even accuse them of doing. And then you're saying they have like
ties to other places. I don't understand like where that's coming
from. Could you show me evidence of that? I just want him to
get evidence. like he's largely accepted I think on faith most
of these things which to me is kind of crazy because when I say
things I feel like Connor wants to go into them I feel like it's
much harder for me to say things and they get accepted on faith
directing his community to hate this person like okay well if
I um if I post anywhere it doesn't count if I ban a message I'm
controlling like basically these people use it's kind of like
the other version of the lefty online debater oh he's damned
if you do damned if you don't hear I where's the damned if you
don't argument where's the if you didn't if you didn't dox these
people would you be like, "Oh, you must not be upset you didn't
dox these people." Connor, please point out how this is getting.
Where is it? Where where is the push back, Connor? Nobody Nobody
was sitting here going like, "Well, Destiny clearly didn't think
this was a problem. He didn't even dox anybody." He didn't even
call for anyone to get killed. Does he think it's a problem?
Really? Could he really say he thinks it's a problem if he hasn't
called for anybody to die? How about you talk with Connor? I
already asked Connor to be on tonight, but I we end up going
late, so I think probably where they'll harass you and then when
you try to say anything back to them, they're like, "Oh, you're
harassing a small content creator." Like the oppressor oppressy
dynamic that because a person might be smaller than me or whatever,
I'm not allowed to say anything back. I reject that framework
entirely. Yeah, actually this is this is actually allowed to
say anything back. Kelly made somewhere along that. Yes, Kelly
made an argument somewhere along that and I just I I upgraded.
Okay, we we have the same argument, but it should be you. It
doesn't give you the right just cuz they're smaller. It doesn't
give you the right to maliciously lie about them. Right. That's
the issue is you maliciously lie in return and violence calls
to violence and calls to action that are deep. Yeah. This is
not just he's acc he's saying oh I can't say anything. It's like
you could still about us in your DGG chat but probably it would
be better for you if that wasn't including doxing violence death
threats and like platforming threats that you've like spoke out
against yourself in the past. It's like you could you could talk
about us without doing that. Sure. Kingler, the issue here is
that the idea that even if that connection could be made in some
way that it would be a valid tactic, that's insane. Do you understand
how mentally rich you have to be to accept that? Oh, actually,
technically, somebody did post a link to Kiwi Farms even though
it was deleted and even though that person got timed out, um,
somebody did post a link and that means it's okay for you to
throw death threat or to call for violence against these people,
right? that that's such a mind rate position to have um on Connor's
part if you're saying that or if anybody else accepts that, right?
Connor is super accepting. Yeah, but I mean I would just say
probably in terms of Destiny being blamed for KeL's getting like
hate rated or something. It's like oh we can't produce proof
that it was my community and if you can't ban those people it's
against the rules. Like realistically I can't be blamed for everything
everybody else does especially when I have policies against the
things that he's saying happen. It's like it's basically
it's basically Kelly has been his pretext, but the the pretext
is insane, too. Talking [__] about his girlfriend.
Like he called for the docks before that was happening. Um I
would say from now on No, hang on. Quick quick thing. Not about
his girlfriend, but he said a lot of things that were far more
hostile about me before I said anything about his girlfriend.
Okay. He brought up assault multiple times. He brought up my
vaginismas and that related and vagina stuff and saying full
thought is base, etc. about all of this stuff, okay? All before
I said anything about his girlfriend and posted a bunch of Yeah,
just weird nasty [__] So, the idea that there was
like nothing directed at me before then is not true. Comparatively,
what I've said about her, oh, I called her oh boohoo is still
not comparative to anything he said or done to me or even the
she said at this point. So, it's like irrelevant really. It's
just the the implication that that therefore calls her harassment
is just not true. I would like to see proof. Okay. I never made
any call to action to harass her or or anybody and I never would
because that's weird and bad behavior. Um, and I've said this
for a while, although my personal life isn't as much in the spotlight
anymore. If you want to criticize me for being like manipulative
or controlling or some [__] then you need to post
examples of that. It's not enough to just say, "Oh, because Destiny
spoke about this on stream. He's abusing his power." That's
um Yeah. You have to show more than that, I think. Yeah. Okay.
And then this is probably that's so perfect. Hold on. Hold on.
That's so perfect. That's so perfect. You have to show examples.
If you claim I'm manipulative, so he's claiming right now that
hey, I just wanted people to stop talking about Anna. When you
actually look at his logs, he basically says you are constantly
talking about me. He says what is making it okay for him to do
this? That is a manipulation. That is applying negative pressure,
saying, "Well, I sure wish you weren't talking about me and then
maybe bad things would stop happening to you." He is manipulating
her to stop talking about him by threatening her. Objectively,
that is what's happening here. Why Why would we pretend anything
else is happening here? Why would he say, "Well, listen, you're
constantly talking about me on your stream, so I think it's fair
for me to bring it up. Your Kiwi Farms thread. You went as far
as to say I was abusive the last time you mentioned me." And
she says, "Oh, you're ruining my life. You put me in danger."
And he says, "You're doing it to yourself." How is that confusing
to anyone? You're you're doing it to yourself. you're going to
keep doing it to yourself. If you keep talking about me, this
will keep happening to you. How is that even remotely confusing
to anybody? That's like super easy right there, right? I don't
literally the example they're using, the proof is there of him
being manipulative. Uh, also don't forget two days before this,
he did this in likely in retaliation for something she'd said
on stream. She explained in the DM exchange below, despite being
on relatively good terms and despite having two days prior. Seriously.
Seriously.
And then he he can go on here and totally with a straight face,
not like just a total lizard person and say, "Well, they'd have
to show proof that I was trying to manipulate somebody by doing
that. I mean, you can't just say me talking about it is bad as
much in the spotlight anymore." If you want to criticize me for
being like manipulative or controlling or some, then you need
to post examples of that. It's not enough to just say, "Oh, because
Destiny spoke about this on stream. He's abusing his power."
That's
Kelly. I'm literally trying to show a quote of the thing I just
spoke about. What are you talking? Why are you talking over the
quote? Because it's the ask for evidence thing. Remember when
he gave me a bunch of [__] for that for me asking
for evidence? Yes. That's why I said stop. Yeah, but we just
watched the clip before, so I thought you were watching it before.
I was replaying it to show I've heard it a couple of times, so
my bad. Okay. Thank you. All right. Okay. I was just trying to
say yes, the evidence is right here. The evidence is right here
of the abuse of the manipulation, right? Sorry, the Jacob thing.
The evidence is in the Jacob thing where he says, "Oh, if you
guys don't stop talking about me in that Discord, I'm gonna post
more about Jacob and Zoe." Where is it? Here. Let me go back
to the the Jacob blog. I brought it up because he specifically
called it an abuse tactic when he was talking about me asking
for evidence in the past. I want examples. He was like, "That's
a Kelly abuse tactic." So, yeah, it's pretty relevant. Or was
the Zoey log? Yeah. He just proved to himself he's abusing people.
He literally keeps saying, "Yeah, uh, I'm going to do more things."
This is after he directed people towards uh he directed people
towards their docs knowing that it had made them leave before.
He just he does it repeatedly and then he can come on and say,
"Hey, post proof of this or else you're lying." It's like, "No,
nobody's lying. What the what are we doing here? How how can
this person be such a lizard? How can they show this little emotion
or this little care or understanding for other people? I don't
like he just he can go on here and just he knows that if he says
these things calmly it will seem like he's telling the truth.
It's disgusting as [__] Yeah, you have to show. I
think that it's also just like um he's aware like he can just
Yeah. His audience just don't care. They don't go to look outside
of like that community to see consent uh dissenting opinions.
So it's just like he can just say what he wants. So it doesn't
really make much difference which is quite depressing really.
The whole cult thing. Yeah. I don't know dude. It's uh it's crazy.
It's really crazy to me. That I think. Yeah. Okay. And then this
is probably the I would say like the last hot question I guess
and then uh I want to dig into like moral perspectives on the
hot question. I guess. Go for it. Uh I if if if you'll indulge
me with an articulation.
Uh, so doxing in my opinion, the reason why so many creators
view it as like a total violation of etiquette is Why are you
expecting decency towards you? I don't get it. All right. I again,
mental rape victim, but I I I would offer for Douggee Chan to
join the Discord, but he joined and got perpetually raped the
last time, and he's just another person like Yogi who's like
a massochist and likes being raped mentally. And it's Listen,
I don't want to be your daddy, okay? Go find somebody else. Is
because we're all creators. We're We're all trying to make surely
you didn't do anything bad to him. What did I do that was What
did I do that was on the level of his conduct? That isn't a response
to him doing some insane escalation. I think the worst thing
I did to him, what was it? What was the worst thing I did to
him? Hold on, Douggeie Chan. Go ahead. What was the worst thing
I did to him? Worst thing I did was call him a fat cheap streamer.
Wait, what did I say? I was a cheap for a cheap fat streamer.
And I would say that again. I mean, I'm just I'm gonna say just
worst thing if you go ahead. Make money on the internet. I'm
not gonna wait. And so as a result, like having law enforcement
officers kick in our doors, having sociopaths show up to our
doorways,
talk [__] about him to his son. What are you? I've
literally never done that ever. uh having people send you know
senders or rape threats or death threats or whatever that is
enabled by
hey I'm sorry I missed the I want to dig into like moral perspectives
on the hot question I guess go for it uh I if if you'll indulge
me doggy chan you've got your next line in this chat to say what
I've done that's really bad with an articulation uh so doxing
in my opinion the reason why so many creat say the worst thing
that I've done to Destiny me doggy chen go ahead creators view
it as like a total violation of etiquette is because we're all
creators we're we're all trying to make money on the internet
and so as a result like
having to cancel them good lord I need you muted in this other
one as well holy [__] you are brain dead law enforcement
officers kick in our doors having sociopaths show up to our doorways
doxing is bad for these pizzas or threaten us or rape threats
or death threats or whatever that is enabled by doxing is a bridge
too far. If we're going to dislike each other and hate each other,
then we should do it here where we talk [__] about
each other, talk [__] about each other's ideas, and
then we just kind of like this is the playing field, not the
real world, right? That's kind of like the doxy etiquette, right?
Okay. And then calling for calling for death, like you know,
uh you know, saying, "Oh, I wish these people would die, etc.,
etc." A lot of people uh including myself sometimes, uh just
to be clear, it was I wish somebody would kill these people.
I wish somebody would kill these people will view that as a stata
a stochcastic call to violence where effectively what you're
doing is if you're getting a dox and you're saying that this
person should die you're kind of hoping that somebody will pull
a John Lennon and you know they'll just be like a skitso and
they'll be like yes sir Mr. Hold on. This is actually Oh my god,
Connor's getting close to asking a a good question and then they'll
show up to one of your critics doorways and then actually
I if Connor accepts uh actually hold on well technically these
guys um they might have used some logs of mine that were that
were formatted on Kiwi Bars. So technically calling for their
death is probably justified. I hope that's not what And so the
the question
is that's the general perception of doxing and death threats
and talking about wanting people dead online. Why uh you kind
of already answered this a little bit, but why did you cross
that line recently? So this is just probably a thing that will
never happen and I understand that and that's fine. I guess I've
come to accept it. I wish that when people would be uh critical
of these positions, I wish they would stop to ask ever like I
wonder why that person said this. Um because I think one of the
great atrocities that has been committed is happening right now
in our political system and it also happens online is listen
nobody wonders everybody just condemns the death threats and
nobody wonders why I did the death threats. Nobody wonders why
I called for these people to die. people will engage in deplorable
behavior and then when somebody um basically returns I will say
repeatedly okay I have repeatedly repeatedly asked Destiny could
you say why this is okay and his best he can do is vaguely allege
that there's some Kiwi Farms like behavior happening in my Discord
that I disavow and have rules against. That's the best he can
do. He's objectively just blaming somebody else's bad conduct
on me and trying to attack me and Queman and Kelly and Mr. Girl
and Lav. Yeah, like it's just But like me specifically, I don't
I don't even know. I feel like where am I lying about this guy?
Turns it in kind. All of a sudden, they cry victim. Um, if people
really truly feel this way about doxing and all that. Also, yes,
obviously Connor just asked. Yes, Connor just asked. It's a little
crazy. Also, my headphones just connect them really quickly.
It's a little crazy when somebody goes, "Hey, Destiny, for the
death of some people, could you tell me why you did that?" And
he's like, "The worst part about all of this is actually the
fact that okay, it's actually the fact that nobody's ever asked
me about this." It's like, "Oh, well, that's not
what what I just asked you. What are we doing?" It sure would
have been interesting to see them say anything about that in
regards to these communities that have been doing it to me for
so long. And at this point, I've been swatted in the past year.
I've been swatted twice. I've had over Oh, were you Wait, was
he swatted because of me? Is that what he's saying? Or was he
swatted because of his Trump comments? Cuz I could have sworn
the the one that happened, the one I knew about was the Trump
comments. No.
Is he trying to web us with just Kiwi farms? We are now Kiwi
Farms. Yes. He's blaming He's blaming me for him getting swatted,
which like And then he said twice. So I know one of those is
the Nathan Trump stuff. The other I don't know if the other stuff
was the Islam stuff or not. Go ahead. Are there were the swatters
even from Kiwi Farms? I have no clue.
I don't think he does either. I actually know he doesn't. They're
all the same people. 100 food deliver according to him. He gets
featured far more than I do. Douggee Chan come up with a better
example. Show up to my apartment. And I've had people that are
doxing my family members, my girlfriend, and basically tons of
people around me. And there are people that are aware of the
communities doing this that still reference those communities,
link to those communities, joke with those communities, and have
other discords created with members of those communities. I have
I But hold on. But he keeps saying people. You're asking. Stop
saying people, Connor. Make him stop saying people and make him
say who names. Specific names. Who names? Give me the links.
Give me Make yourself sound like an insane psychopath and connect
the dots to me or Quean or somebody else you've called for the
death of. Please connect the dots. Please stop just vaguely like
alleging this. Stop vaguely gesturing at some pattern that you
haven't proven out. some conspiracy that exists, okay? And connect
the dots. Stop letting him get away with not connecting the dots.
Zero care in the world for you crying about anything that I It's
just insane because there's just so many degrees of separation
between if we were to reference something from Kiwi Farms, it's
not the same as directly linking to something like illegal content
on Kiwi Farms. It's just like this implication is just not true.
But also, at no point have anyone wanted to like encourage to
go see that stuff anyway. Everyone here thinks doxing is bad.
We're not telling anyone to turn up to someone's house and go
kill them. That's just everyone here knows that's weird. I don't
know. Yeah, I don't know. Apparently, because I criticize Destiny
and the criticisms get posted on Kiwi Farms, that is apparently
I can be blamed for everything Kiwi Farms does then and then
they can call for my death and try to dox me. That's like that's
the world that Destiny is setting up and Connor is accepting
this right now and that's very concerning. I hope he pushes really
hard back against this including stuff that happened
before this stuff happened like all of the swatting stuff. I
think that happened before the pixie stuff. Surely
the doxing was already done before. Some of it was I just I don't
know. Yeah. I just don't understand how we could live in that
world where it's like uh yeah you your clips got posted there.
That's like the the world of the cognitively rigged. I don't
I don't want to say about you whatsoever. And I wish other people
had a similar perspective because I think you're enabling that
behavior. If you want to live in a world where we don't talk
about docs or anything like that, that's fine. But you need to
take a it has to be a proactive stance against it. It can't be
a Well, we've never posted your full address in our Discord,
so it's okay. That's my position on it. There's a literally a
proactive stance and has been for weeks. I I don't know. There's
always been a proactive stance against this in my Discord. You
can't post like KF links. You can't post images of KF posts.
They get removed. They've been getting removed forever. So, it's
the uh plain cute and cross-pollination between the psycho communities
and the drama communities. Yeah, but it's not just cross-pollination.
Like, it is an active coordination between these communities.
It is very active. Uh I unbanned Lav after he tried to dox me.
Yo, sorry. That's I unbanned Lav in response to him trying to
dox me. Everyone talks about the the Lav thing as if any of us
saw it. None of us saw it and also why the were we seeing his
dick anyway was already years ago. Nothing like this obviously
then like everybody knows like people like DMing between these
communities and she needs I'm confused.
Okay then. I mean I'll I'll accept that then the yeah she she
posted it in a different server literally somewhere else entirely.
None of us have seen it. Obviously was criticized wildly for
it. Got timed out for a long period of time. The next thing is
actually a quote from Richard Nixon that I being angry at something
as a concept like yogi. You've never seen it. You don't know
who saw what and how big of a deal it really was. You're taking
Destiny's word for it. It's just like why would you do that?
Um, also Destiny had his dickpick revenge put in the Kiwi Farms
thread and then he signed up and participated in Kiwi Farms the
whole time with pictures of his in there. If you want to live
in a world where we don't. So like I don't know like clearly
this wasn't a problem for him before he interacted with spaces
like that before he was totally fine with it right talk about
docs or anything like that that's fine but you need to take a
it has to be a proactive st no we're not fine with docs by the
way at all yeah nope nobody ever has been we've never and all
of this stuff even stuff that's alluding to anything like that
would get removed those people would be kicked those people would
be timed out at minimum depending on what it was right like there
are times where people have like Like obviously it's a community
where people cam up and [__] There have been times
where like I think um and this isn't to do with Destiny. I think
community members have posted like stuff that could be considered
private that was recalled from previous things or searched based
on like VCs with uh like cams on or something. But like that's
about as bad as it gets and those people get timed out. I don't
know. Like they've done
Yeah, it's doc. I think that probably happens in most places.
Like I I don't know anywhere where you have a community where
people can come up and like talk about each other and share private
[__] But like that's just within the community that
all gets handled. It's like strongly discourage. It can't be
do this. Yeah. Yeah. And the again the Kiwi Farms thing rules
against that. Tons of rules against that. Well, we've never posted
your full address in our Discord, so it's okay. That's my position
on it. No one's posted any address in the Discord. Well, he's
No, he was uh he was he was saying you have to take a proactive
role. You can't just have that thing. Uh, but I would say there's
a proactive role against that information being posted. I don't
know. He's he's apparently said um his girlfriend's like old
link tree is something that is Doc's information. Doesn't really
make sense to me, but hey, it was linked on her Instagram. This
link tree was linked on her Instagram. Her public open unprivated
Instagram.
Krispy, thank you for the uh Yeah, sure. Krispy, thank you for
the raid. Thank you. Thank you. Yeah. Wow. So anyway, so that
that is his position, but I would say based on a baseline that
is the position of my discord is we have a proactive stance against
that and we have for a long period of time like way longer than
he's been calling for docs for plain cute. Doc doesn't have to
be private info. Um disingenuous lying prick. I don't but I I
don't know if it could be info you publicly promote and make
money from promoting, right? Like if I'm an influencer and I
put my real name on my Tik Tok, my influencer Tik Tok, and then
people post my influencer Tik Tok, a screenshot of it, how much
is that doxing me? I don't know. I'd say the longer it was taken
down for and if it was a mistake, depending on how long it was
there for, how long it stayed there for, like there's probably
some movement around. I But if I'm like publicly promoting that
information, I don't know if you can I don't know if you can
call that doxing
and crosspollination. But also, just quickly, there was no doc
info on that link either. It was just a link to her my free cams
and to her only fans and stuff, but it was no docs information
on that link and it was linked on her private uh on her public
sorry Instagram. But it's no not a doc categorically in any way.
She's just embarrassed that she was a cam girl and now wants
to hide it and pretend she's
What's Kingler? What's the call to action? I don't even know
what the call to action would be between the psycho communities.
Wait, hold on. I hold on. I I have a hard time seeing if there's
any actual criticism of that. Wait, do people have a criticism
of hey, this person had like a public my free cams that was posted
in as a part of their like their standard links that they have
attached everywhere? Is that is that doxing? What what was the
context it was posted in even? I have no idea. I don't even think
I posted the link. I just laughed because somebody told me that
she had deleted it. Okay. I have no clue. Is that is that doxing?
No, because there's no private information. A doc would be like
a name or like the address or like what's other private info?
I don't know.
This douge Chen guy is giving me so much KCAP info. I look over
in the other thing and he's just asking the most questions. Just
a troll. This is This guy's on the Queen guy level now. Did Destiny
dox Mike from PA? Oh, is this This is like the same thing, isn't
it? It would be like the mic from PA thing. Interesting.
And the drama communities. Yeah, but it's not just cross-pollination.
Like it is an active coordination between these communities.
It is very active. Intent is the main factor. No, no, it wouldn't
be the main factor. It would be a contributing factor. But like
even if I if I post like Destiny's like I don't know if we were
to post like his Twitch link. Let's say he was on Twitch. Is
that And I don't like him. Is that doxing or is that just like
I don't like this person so I'm harassing them. I don't think
that's doxing. I think that's just I don't like this person so
I'm posting them laughing at them. I think that qualifies as
harassment.
Posting someone's public link. Yeah. I don't know. I don't know.
If mean things said about people is harassment, then we're all
and destiny more so than
I just don't know how we could possibly get any better than that.
And like everybody knows it. Like people are DMing. Apparently,
we need to ban people who might post links to people they don't
like. Linking somebody's social media page when they're a paid
social media influencer is doxing according to DG. I can't imagine
being more than this, but they delve to deeper levels at all
times and [__] So, okay, then I mean I'll I'll accept
that then the
really you'll just accept that. Sorry, I have to go back. So,
it's the uh plain cute and cross-pollination between the psycho
communities and the drama communities. Yeah, but it's not just
crosspollination.
Hold on one second. I would say probably. Was this before or
after you got in that fight with her where she tweeted about
you, Kelly? Sorry. What was before or after? Did she delete before
or after that? A good question. I'm not sure. Well, I I was just
saying that she like she basically shamed you for being a like
an Only Fans woman, too. Yeah. Well, she said more specifically
than that, she accused me of being on welfare benefits or disability
benefits, which is odd because I'm not. and then called me said
I was aging out of being a [__] So, and criticized
my lack of I guess pension or something or like she assumes like
uh she knows anything about my money. I'm not entirely sure,
but it was from my perspective, it was projection because she
lives with her parents slash in an apartment that Destiny pays
for is nearly 30 and doesn't have any education skills or anything
other than being a cam girl. So yeah, I just say you guys were
fight and I don't know whatever. It is an active coordination
talking about herself as far as I'm aware. Yeah, but it's not
just crosspollination like it is an active coordination between
these communities. is very active.
Active in what way? Where's the active coordination? I don't
know where the active coordination is. What's the active coordination?
Like everybody knows it. Okay. Like people are DMing between
these communities and [__] So, bro, I don't talk.
I barely talk to Queen, let alone other people. She has a loving
heart that tolerates
a true. I don't I literally don't get it. Okay, then. I mean,
I'll I'll accept that then. Quan Queen, he's just Wait, you'll
accept that? Wait, where's the proof? What do you mean you'll
accept that? What the is that? Where is Connor coming from where
he just accepts that? I'll accept that. What? What? I How do
we not need any proof there? Destiny
posits massive conspiracy. Connor blindly accepts. Oh, I know.
I know what this will turn into. This will turn into this argument.
Well, if Destiny actually believes it, then is this really that
bad? And then every single DJer who I completely mercilessly
raped by pointing out that that's the argument Trumpsters use
for why he didn't actually try to take over the election, right?
Well, he thought he won. Isn't that Isn't that okay? If he, you
know, if he thought he won, does that mean he is not trying to
steal the election? And then people's brains will melt, I guess.
That's just like
I don't know. The next thing is actually a quote from Richard
Nixon that I watched earlier this stream. Oh, good. and he was
saying that a lot of people appeal to the golden rule right treat
others as you want to be treated and he was talking about Russia
and he's like well with Russia uh the golden rule doesn't work
and so the golden rule that you have to abide by is do unto Russia
as they are do doing unto you and then Henry Kissinger said plus
10%. And so my question is uh often times with uh Christian morality
uh there there's always an appeal to turn the other cheek and
and I'm not saying that you should do this. I'm asking for your
moral perspective. Are you I just I can't imagine I literally
just can't imagine DJs actually fully turning into Trumpsters.
It's just wild. An eye for an eye. Old testament do unto others
as they are doing to you. They're they're actually they've actually
reached the point where they're like going to start going um
anything that owns J-stock is based because it owns Jtock. That's
that's where they're at. It's amazing. Instead of crashing the
economy to own libs, permitting death threats to own JSTO. Let's
go. Do unto others what you wish they would do to you. I mean,
I like I'll treat anybody with respect initially. like all of
my initial like I'm always going to give somebody the benefit
of the doubt initially, but I'm not going to go out of my way
to do favors for you or to be protective of you if you're going
out of your way to be like destructive. Uh I've got a bunch of
clips from this Ry me and I don't think anybody should have that
expectation. Okay. So, so do you think that uh not so the the
classic saying is uh treat treat others as you would like to
be treated. uh you'll use that, if I'm hearing you correctly,
you'll use that as an initial like uh etiquette, but then once
it goes hard, it kind of goes to do unto others as they are doing
to you. Yeah. Or I'll just assume they're living by that etiquette.
But if we wait, Jason can't hold on, Jason. I just want I just
want to make sure you understand the hypothetical. So, if Kelly
Jean deleted her link tree tomorrow and then the next day I mocked
her and laughed at her for deleting her link tree and like said
what the link tree was, we consider that a low-level doc.
I believe that's what we're saying the happened here.
That is so dumb. It's also not even harassment unless you told
other people to do stuff. If you said go harass Kelly via Twitter
or something, then yeah, that's harassment. I mean, I'm not going
to say that. I think I could easily go post like a Tom Fury link
in my Discord and we could go watch Tom Fury and I would be concerned
if I just said, "Oh, let's go look at this." I Okay. Well, you
might be in that position, but I'm not, am I? People don't just
harass people because I post or talk about something, right?
That's still not a situation. I don't have that power, bro. I
still don't know. I again, even if even if let's say Kelly had
posted uh like a private Instagram that nobody knew about of
Destiny's girlfriend, okay? Like actual sort of doxing information,
would that justify him calling for my death? Cuz that's his argument,
right? Is like that justifies him calling for my death and trying
to dox me. I mean, I guess m maybe you could make the argument,
but I would just ban Kelly if she did something like that. If
she was posting like PII like per like what would you call it?
Proprietary like PII that she'd found on her own, I would just
ban Kelly. That wouldn't be acceptable by any means to you. Yeah.
Or I'll just assume they're living by that etiquette of doing
to others. Yeah. For that you would want them to do to you know
people that did
that behavior. I guess they don't care about it then. Uh cuz
it's not the same thing. And then uh my this is a question that
I think again. Let's go. Logically extends which is just uh how
Do you think that this extends out into where we're obviously
in the Trump era of like mutually assured destruction
parties about the brinksmanship or violence or death in politics
that they're causing and so as a result it doesn't seem like
turning I need to go back and analyze this for and uh harassing
behavior I I guess I don't care about it then. Okay. And then
uh my this is a question that I think logically extends uh which
is just uh how how do you think that this extends out into our
current politics? He's talk running so hard. It's it's crazy.
I'm just like uh I'm sitting here. I'm just trying to like analyze
this and Kelly's like wait this goes back to a previous argument
that we had and now I can bring that up. It's like, dude, I'm
trying to analyze this where we're obviously in the Trump era
of like mutually assured destruction, where our
counterparties don't seem to care about the brinksmanship or
violence or death in politics that they're causing. And so, as
a result, it doesn't seem like turning the other cheek works.
And by the way, I believe Kelly, if if I brought this up as like,
"Hey, clearly this was annoying." She'd be like, "But she didn't
ask me to stop." She will literally make that argument that I
didn't ask her to stop. So obviously she would keep doing it
or something. It's also it doesn't really seem that like reciprocals
or political violence works. Bring Kelly back. I think being
reciprocal does work. I don't think the reciprocity has happened.
I think that's why we're at the point we are now. Actually reciprocity
hasn't happened. I can't I literally can't be reciprocal on him.
I'm not willing to do the things that he's willing to do. He's
like he's like I'm now the uh Democrat. I actually should probably
try to be reciprocal in some way. I have no way. There's no reciprocity
I can engage in. I can't do those things back to him, the things
he's done to me. Right. I think that when people are turning
the cheek for too long. Um not kind of, but like nobody has viewed
it as turning the cheek. People have engaged in a whole bunch
of weird behavior to either pretend that the other side had done
it first or that um that one side wasn't doing a particular thing.
Like I think there's a pretty strong deterrent effect when people
see behavior as like unacceptable. But when people start to normalize
that behavior or see it as acceptable, then people have, you
know, a certain view on it or they'll cry victim when it happens
to them. But yeah, I think that that reciprocity is a really
important tit for tat type of thing. Yeah, the tit for tat here
doesn't exist. I've not done anything like this to Destiny. I
haven't supported any of these things happening to Destiny, right?
I've literally and especially the people around him. I've disavowed
hard the whole time. Um Quimman's never once avowed the things
around him, right? That's never happened. But he will advocate
for these things. He has done these things himself. There's no
reciprocity here. He's just going sicko mode for no reason. Okay.
Um I have uh one more point question and then I have uh personal
questions that might be too personal for you to answer and I'm
okay. I It's sad that like Counterpoints isn't just pointing
out that there's no reciprocity. Like it's he's literally pulled
out a gun and tried to shoot me after I like called him a fat.
Like I called him fat and now he's pulled out a gun and tried
to shoot me. There's not it's not close to reciprocity with you
saying like, "Hey, this is too personal." So the the first thing
is let's say we're a year out the the court case is either settled
uh or it's done in whatever way and you are effectively free
from whatever shackles that were uh put on you socially and politically
in order to pursue your own ambitions uh both IRL and online.
What is the next project once everything is settled? I'm not
really sure right now. Like in the prior thing, the thing that
I was looking at the most was like a media probably still continue
to do stuff PV uh in the the reason why I'm asking um this this
is the engine of those 1.6 million voter contacts. Yeah, for
sure. And so so my
not that we know those did anything. By the way, Connor was asked
like how do you know how that translated into anything? Annoyance,
I guess. Uh, part of the reason why I wanted to have this conversation
was because if we waste that community effort, that energy in
order to try to have a real world impact, I'll view that as a
I don't know. We were talking about like wait, oh my god, this
guy is like totally mind release. God,
don't quote Douggee Chan because I can't I can't ignore quotes
to him. So, don't don't quote the just like ignore. He's He's
just trolling now because he got so humiliated on stream that
he's just gonna troll and pretend that he was actually trying
to act. He's just doing the I was only pretending to be thing.
He's actually just being a complete [__] now. Trying
to pretend that he wasn't representing his real positions and
wasn't getting completely done stream world duties or something.
Um I would view that as like a destruction of the prescriptive
moral duty. Uh so you kind of already answered my question, but
I just want to share my perspective on that. Yeah, I think that
would probably be bad. Yeah, this is the What's up, Nandros?
This is the ethics of eating queen panel. It could be gains.
I'm actually almost Sorry, what's that? I think there's a lot
of potential to do like politically active stuff. Um, it's one
of my biggest complaints. Oh, Asia. I'm not saying I'm calling
him fat. I was saying the the desperate the desperate the distance
between the two actions is just insane, right? Like the the escalation
he's gone to is insane. I haven't called him fat broadly because
I'm like not skinnier than Destiny. Okay. I'll just say that
obviously I'm I'm 5'11 185. I'm like not skinny. He's probably
Well, maybe we have the same body fat percentage, but like I'm
not like that much skinnier than him. So like I wouldn't call
him fat. This is not an insult I throw at people who are like
not morbidly obese. Although you could call him morbidly obese
if you wanted. Um that's funny. But like I'm saying that I basically
called him I called him what I called him like an evil beast.
It's like, dude, you violated a bunch of people's consent. Even
in that, even calling him an e. I'll just say I called him an
e. He tried to He's like now calling for me to die. I don't think
that's I don't think that's fine at all. I didn't say I was fat.
I said I I don't know how this this guy's like 135,
right? I don't I don't know. It's about all lefting creators
online is that they don't seem to do anything. So, yeah, I would
want to continue to do stuff like that if possible. Yeah. Okay.
Then, uh these questions might be too personal. Uh but they are
also the last things that I had written down. Uh so you can either
just say hey I don't want to talk about that or you can answer
it depending on your view. Okay. So uh how do you view uh people
gave me because I described some of your uh known upbringings.
How do you view your child? I heard about this. Um Oh no. That's
a super broad question. Um there are some things that I had struggles
with. There are some things that were like super beneficial.
Um it just depends. I would say on the net I think I was probably
like way better off than definitely most people in the world.
Probably better off I think than most people in the country hopefully
maybe or at least in the upper 50. I I'm I made a psychological
argument and you and a historical argument and you can disagree
with me. Okay. Um there was a piece of content that was called
my early life was bizarre or something and it's it's probably
like this is really I don't know why you would bring this one
up. I don't I actually don't know. I actually don't know a decade
old. Uh it might be like eight years old now. Uh but one of the
things that you talked about was effectively the fact that uh
your parents were so busy with their side hustles and their shenanigans
that often times you were alone and so you had to be emotionally
reliant on yourself and resilient. Sure. Yeah. Probably a lot
of resiliency growing up. Yeah. The main reason why I don't like
to do the psychoanalysis stuff is because um there's a lot of
people that have I would say the the norm is nobody really cares
to try to understand anything. People are usually just digging
through my past because they want to explain or pathize some
behavior. So, in my mind, most of those conversations are incredibly
boring because it's just people looking to affirm whatever like
biases they have of me. I think this is an as he pointed out
that um Erodite does this. This is literally he just described
Erdite's behavior onetoone with him that she pathologizes all
of his bad behavior and explains it all away through pathologizing
his previous bad behavior, right? Using that his his childhood
trauma as the actual reason for it. Yeah. I don't know. I don't
know if anybody wants to point out that that's precisely what
Aerodite does, but hey, incredibly common behavior. Well, then
then I'll I'll cut to the chase. Okay. So, my argument would
be that uh your your childhood experiences and in particular
getting emotionally attached to some of the uh animals that your
grandma took care of and then them being euthanized without a
good reason uh would be partially responsible for your emotional
callousness.
It's possible. Sure. Yeah. Okay. I can't say it's impossible.
Sure. Everything impacted me growing up. Yeah. Okay. Why we try
andize the [__] murderer rapist? I mean, if you're
just saying possible, I'm putting it at PL. Pathology equals
a second unconscious self that doesn't define you. For every
other person in the world, the pathology is a part of you. Yeah.
I mean, you have to integrate the the negative things that you've
grown up with, the negative parts of your personality. You have
to integrate them somehow and make them work. You have to figure
out how to operate day-to-day with them. If you don't, you're
just going to keep hurting people. Hurt. We're doing the hurt
people hurt people thing again. Possible. I'm going to argue
with you about your own life experience. Well, I mean like like
I mean approaching the past with some humility. I mean like it
could be that some things had a dramatic impact. I mean I don't
even realize it. It could be that some things that I thought
were super impactful were nowhere near as impactful. I don't
know. I can't really say but yeah I mean I'm sure on that
matter not child. Okay. And then um you you have a a teenage
boy right? Yep. So, so the you know your kids obviously kids
they look up to their parents, they look up to role models in
society. You also have tens of thousands of young men who listen
to you on a day-to-day basis as a streamer. Um, so what parts
of you do you wish that they would emulate and what parts of
you do they wish they wouldn't have for people in general or
for my own son? I would love to hear answers to both. What What
do you What do you do that you want if Nathan does it when he's
an adult, you would be proud of him for doing? Sure. And then
what things do you do that you would be like I wish he would
avoid that? I mean I guess uh I mean I feel like I'm a very independent
person which I think is generally good. So ideally um you know
the the problem is like every trade can be good and every trade
can be bad. So I'm very independent. The it would have been so
nice if Connor had pressed on this at all and just asked for
like proof of these things. Proof that I like support any of
it. Proof that I'm not like sitting here making rules against
the things that Destiny said that that weren't in place like
weeks ago, months ago. I don't know. It's just it's crazy side
of that is that I can be extremely unique and thoughtful when
it comes to approaching certain political issues or certain life
related issues. There's a lot like that unique um thoughtful
aspect is good. The flip side of that is that I could also be
stubborn. Uh I literally don't care. I actually don't give a
[__] Don't give a [__] about this
anymore. Wait, hold on. Wait. There isn't um there isn't more
content there at the end, is there? Wait. I didn't actually Hold
on. Wait. I might have skipped. I might skip. Here's a common
talking point that I've heard. No, the final question. Yeah.
Sure, sure, sure, sure. [__] Okay. Well, he's a doctor
and a CEO and he's a doctor in psychology. We're moving from
Yeah. Oh, another thing I would say, um, and I've absolutely
and utterly failed in communicating this to my fan base. Hopefully
Nathan does a better job, but who knows? Um, I really value,
um, I really value, uh, variety in people. So I think a person
who's capable of enjoying uh you know like like like sports and
video games or science and art or philosophy and computer programming
like having a variety of traits and appreciating. Sorry. What
of those things is he good at any of them?
Sports when he like goes up the stairs
also like literally getting like buying buying nudes and feet
pics from like a high schooler. Uh, which one of those was she
good at? I of people I think is I think is one of the coolest
traits of of a person. What hobbies does this man have other
than like being bad at most things? Taking 6 months to deal with
the audio in your studio. And sorry, what hobbies and interest
does your current girlfriend have? I'd love to know. You're both
hobbyless losers. Yeah. Uh, I will just point out that yeah,
the the high schooler who he's paying for like feed pics images
from, um, who he shared all of his breakup DMs with Lauren Southern
to and his therapy document, I believe. Although, I actually
don't know for sure in the therapy document. No, maybe not the
therapy document. Not with that one. But I'm just saying like
he did those things, right? He did those things and then he's
like, "Yeah, that's what I really value. I value variety in people."
What did she have a variety of that you were trusting her with
all these like deeply personal things? Apparently, I don't I
don't even know. I successfully baited me into saying, "What
are your hobbies other than Discord, Kelly?" I mean, I will happily
talk about all of my hobbies. So, I I sing. I have like qualifications.
You can do that on your stream. I'm going to keep watching this.
Sorry, I don't failed
in that would be a thing that I would hope my son would take
up. Yeah, cuz you can learn a lot of different interesting things
from a lot of different types of people. And most people are
only capable of like existing in their own community or doing
their own hobbies and they don't see any value in stuff that's
too far outside the perimeters of that. Okay, cool. Then uh that
wraps up my things, but I want to do one more mental exercise
and uh it's something that I bumped into recently that talks
about false idols. Uh it's a Jordan Peterson and Dr. Arthur Brooks
thing. And uh basically there's four things: money, pleasure,
power, and fame. Okay. And with these four things, the goal is
to figure out which thing you value the most. And so, as a result,
elimination, I just I can't trust the guy who sent pictures of
him sucking to a 19-year-old who he only knew because he bought
nudes from her and then when those got leaked, he was like, "Oh,
guys, I'm the victim." Right? Like a after after doing this and
sharing around of everybody else and then going, "Guys, listen.
I'm the biggest victim here." Right? exposing the privacy of
Lauren, of Molina, psychological, the the psych profile of Molina,
the psych document with Molina, the all of the things he did
with this 19-year-old. And then I I have to take this guy seriously.
Like I should trust his opinion or respect his opinion on everything.
He doesn't think anything through. He's got no he's got nothing.
It's just it's like it actually makes me physically ill feel
physically ill to watch this person for an extended period of
time. I don't know how people do it
Like he's just the least trustworthy, most disgusting person
I can think of that like I've ever consumed a decent amount of
content from. I It's It's actually stomach turning. What's that?
The the correct answer is power is the thing that should be most
valued.
Yeah. Uh like that's just a stupid question. But it but it's
not. And and the reason why is because there's different kinds
of human being. Well, and by the way, I don't care if we open
it up. So if vegan gains I don't I don't know Stephen if you
still want to hang out. Yeah. What's that? Yeah, you can open
up a little. Sure. Okay. So, so the sounds like a woman like
would ask that kind of stupid question. It's like a multiple
choice question a woman would come up with. Like women tend.
So, so hold on. Vegan gains. Let me explain it and let me fight
with you a little bit. Okay. So, the point is there are people
who value money more than power because with power comes a correlated
amount of responsibility. And then there are people who value
pleasure. Yes, there are people who value pleasure more than
anything else. We're we're moving from one segment into the alcohol
and
a requisite amount of power.
Um also have outcome you want
then power would be the correct over there because if you value
anything if you are an idiot but I'm guessing somebody who wants
money interrelated with assume that this question is just silly
okay then what words would you
use way like you're the president of the United mansion
um and world or you could makes more sense. Okay. Did I skip
him asking the question? Because my guess is the second highest
thing you probably do would probably be the something related
to like the training, right? Yeah. Again, if if you don't contextualize
these things and you just define power as the ability to effectuate
whatever outcome you want, then the other like the other way
that priorit value sequentially until you arrive at the final
answer. I I I understand that. But when you ask these questions
generally, the power one the power answer makes all the other
questions completely irrelevant. If it's generalized,
if it's more specific and contextual, that's a different story.
Um, and eating a certain particular diet. Why is because you
can get pleasure through fulfilling your duties. So, you get
pleasure through public advocacy for ve they talk about Warhammer
veganism and through working out and getting fit and all that
kind of stuff. But I think that most people would not call you
a traditional
fundamentally,
um, fulfilling your desires is pleasurable. And if your desire
is just like instant gratification and you don't care about helping
people or bettering yourself or any of these things that a lot
of other people value, then your pleasure- seeeking behavior
will be things like casual, drugs, hair most
unless it's
dude really free time if they want and I know that Queen and
Jess love to fantasize it. I just see it as a stupid question.
Uh, Queman said that I'm gay if I don't ask this question. Yeah.
Uh, were were were you ever didd as a kid? That's Oh, it's a
really weird question. I'll we'll just say uh people can have
their own some fantasies about me in their free time if they
want. I know that Queman and just and the answer is yeah, and
he talks about it. There's like a Reddit post of him talking
about it, but whatever.
It's like not something you can sit here and like mock with a
straight face. So, I love to fantasize about that. Listen, Queman,
you DM'd me. You asked me to ask the question. I asked the question.
I'm not gay, by the way. That's from like a primary source. I
believe he tells women about it, just so you know. Weird. Just
to prove it's from a primary source. Little detail. Uh, no, actually,
never mind. I don't want to I It's actually I don't want to talk
about it really. So, I I can just prove that it's not something
taken from like KF or something. I'm not going to throw any details
out here. Uh, yeah. I got sent it by by somebody on Reddit and
then I got sent it by other people who were like, "He told me
this thing and I just don't use it." So, and Stephen gave you
an answer. So, uh there there we go. Okay. All right. Well, well,
uh Vegan Gains, I'm gonna I'm gonna add you. I uh I Okay, that
that hit less hard than I uh thought it would, but cool. I wish
Quinn would have asked for like, "Hey, Connor, why didn't why
did you not need any proof of any of the webbing he did?" would
be probably just the better question. Like, why did you not want
any proof of that? Why did you just accept that like death threats
are okay if I say they're okay? Why did we Why did we accept
that? Why was that okay? I don't know. Weird.
I want to leave your Maybe.
Because I don't know why he's accepting all of these things being
said about your Discord if he's in your Discord. Nope. Surely
he would just know most of this stuff isn't true. Nope. He's
just there though. Guess he's just blind, I guess. So, Darius
said he wanted to debate you. Uh, I have no interest in debating
Darius. He's not a serious person. There'd be like other people
around Darius I might debate, but I don't need to talk to Darius
or debate him. I He's not a serious person. He is a total all
cow. This is like Chris Chan coming to me. I want to debate something.
Like, no. I I actually see him as that now entirely. So, that's
content. I get that you guys think it's content. Um, trust me,
I don't have that policy for like anyone else. just for Darius
alone, a very disgusting person that I don't want like I just
Yeah, I know. Like I've just heard some of the story. It's like
he's actually just like a really toxic disgusting person that
I don't want to talk to. Yeah, I've been saying that for years
as well. Yeah, it's not even that he's a local. He is a total
loco. He's always been a total loco, but actually he's just like
a really disgusting person that I don't want to talk to. So,
what's next? Uh next is I'm rating out. So, W content, W stream.
Um, I realize I have more time on. I don't know. I'll do more
tomorrow or something. But yeah, I'm going to raid out after
this. Okay. But yeah, W stream. We'll be back tomorrow. Almost
6 hours. Cool. All right. Uh, yeah. I'm not out. I'm just ending.
We'll talk to you guys later.